Herzlich willkommen, seit gegrüßt zum Blue Moon auf Fritz heute mit mir, Konrad Spremberg und dem Chaos Radio. Da nehmen wir uns immer zwei Stunden Zeit am Donnerstagabend alle zwei Monate, um über das Internet zu sprechen, über Netzpolitik, die digitale Gesellschaft. Das ist so der große Themenrahmen. Es geht da, glaube ich, in alle Richtungen, in die es irgendwie gehen kann. Und dafür sind auch heute, wie immer, Gäste im Studio vom Berliner Chaos Computer Club. Aber bevor ich euch diese Gäste vorstelle, die heute hier sind im Studio und bevor wir über unser großes Thema heute Abend reden, über WannaCry, nämlich diesen großen Trojaner-Angriff von vor knapp zwei Wochen, den ihr mit Sicherheit auch mitbekommen habt, auch wenn ihr nur irgendwie die Nachrichten verfolgt habt. Bevor wir darüber sprechen und bevor ich euch meine Gäste vorstelle, schalten wir zu zwei Mitgliedern vom CCC, die nicht hier sein können, die nicht hier sind, vielleicht nicht hier sein wollen heute Abend. Denn sie sind bei einem schönen Event der Gulasch Programmier-Nacht in Karlsruhe. Linus sagt ganz kurz, dass für alle, die den CCC und dieses Event nicht kennen, das hat nichts mit Gulaschessen zu tun oder doch?
Doch, natürlich, das hat was mit Gulaschessen zu tun. Hier gibt es jeden Abend Gulasch, nur morgen nicht. Da gibt es zur Abwechslung so Janka, weil die Leute nicht die ganze Zeit Gulasch kochen wollen.
Ihr könnt neidisch sein, merkt ihr. Auf Linus Neumann, Sprecher vom Chaos Computer Club. Wir wollen mit dir, weshalb wir zu dir schalten, zur Gulasch Programmier-Nacht kurz über ein ebenfalls sehr aktuelles Netzthema sprechen, was wir jetzt zu Anfang der Sendung ja quasi kurz abarbeiten wollen. Es ist auch in den Nachrichten gewesen in den letzten Tagen und Wochen, weil es durch verschiedene Instanzen gegangen ist, die so ein Gesetzgebungsverfahren mit sich bringt. Es geht nämlich um ein neues Gesetz. Es ist, behaupte ich, das Gesetz mit dem schönsten Namen ever. Es heißt Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz. Dahinter steht Heiko Maas. Und es gibt viele Menschen, die sagen, ach, Heiko, dieses Gesetz, da hast du was verbockt. Bevor wir darüber reden, was diese Menschen denken, kannst du, Linus, uns bitte einmal kurz erklären, was Heiko Maas sich gedacht hat. Also was soll dieses Gesetz, das Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz bewirken? Der hat ja eine gute Idee dahinter.
Also was er sich dabei gedacht hat, kann ich beim besten Willen nicht sagen. Aber was er bezwecken wollte ist, das Problem ist ja, und ich denke, dieses Problem würden wir alle zugeben und die Meinung teilen, dass es das gibt, der Hass im Internet nimmt irgendwie zu. Wir haben am laufenden Band irgendwelche Fälle, wo Leute im Internet beschimpft werden, beleidigt werden, über sie Unwahrheiten verbreitet werden in sozialen Netzwerken und die Menschen scheinbar wenig Handhabe dagegen haben. Sie sind dann irgendwie so diesem Hass im Netz ausgesetzt und man scheint irgendwie da so rechtlich selten was gegen Unternehmen zu können. Diese Sachen stehen dann lange im Netz und werden nicht gelöscht und dieses Problem soll gelöst werden. Da hat man sich gedacht, naja, machen wir es einfach so. Wenn eine Beschwerde eingeht bei so einem sozialen Netzwerk, dann sind die in Zukunft verpflichtet, die innerhalb von 24 Stunden zu bearbeiten und entsprechende Inhalte aus ihrem Netz dann oder von ihrer Plattform zu löschen. Und zwar dann, wenn diese Inhalte rechtswidrig sind, nach geltenden Gesetzen. Wir haben ja eine Meinungsfreiheit in Deutschland und wir haben relativ viele verschiedene Gesetze, was man eben dann mal nicht sagen darf, welche Zeichen man nicht verwenden darf, was eine Beleidigung ist und was eine Meinungsäußerung. Und diese Entscheidung sollen dann eben die sozialen Netzwerke innerhalb von 24 Stunden treffen und die Beiträge löschen. Und wenn sie das nicht tun, dann zahlen sie empfindlich hohe Strafen.
Also man bekommt als Nutzer, zumindest in der Theorie, so ein bisschen mehr Sicherheit. Die kümmern sich auch echt um das, was ich da von denen möchte. Nämlich, dass die sich auseinandersetzen mit was, wovon ich mich zum Beispiel beleidigt fühle. Das ist so die Idee dahinter. Und jetzt hast du aber gerade schon gesagt, also wir haben eine Meinungsfreiheit in Deutschland und du oder ihr vom Chaos Computer Club sagt, dieser Gesetzentwurf, wenn das so durchkommt, dann beschränkt das Ganze die Meinungsfreiheit, dann bedroht das die. Warum denkt ihr das? Warum ist das so?
Also das sagen nicht nur wir vom Chaos Computer Club, das sagen auch die Branchenverbände, also wirklich alle, selbst so die Amadeo Antonio Stiftung, die sich sehr stark gegen Hass im Netz einsetzt, sagt, dass dieses Gesetz nicht in Ordnung ist in dieser Form. Das Problem ist folgendes, hier wird eine Entscheidung darüber, ob etwas strafrechtlich relevant ist oder nicht, nicht mehr von Juristen und von unserer Justiz gefällt, sondern von Leuten, die dazu jetzt nicht unbedingt ausgebildet sind oder geschult sind.
Von den Netzwerken.
Von den Netzwerken selber. Das wird ja jetzt auch kein Premium-Job sein. Das werden also nicht besonders geschulte Leute, also im Zweifelsfall keine Juristen sein, die diese Entscheidung dann eben treffen müssen. Und das ist schon mal grundsätzlich nicht in Ordnung, wenn wir sagen, wir lassen justizrelevante Fragestellungen privatisiert entscheiden und durchsetzen. Das weitere Problem ist, dass die Leute, die diese Entscheidung treffen, oder die Unternehmen, die diese Entscheidung dann für die Justiz treffen, eine empfindliche Strafe bekommen, wenn sie fälschlicherweise etwas nicht löschen, aber keine Strafe bekommen, wenn sie fälschlicherweise etwas löschen. Das heißt, wenn wir also so am Rande sind bei so einer Äußerung, nehmen wir mal dieses Böhmermann Gedicht. Da haben wir monatelang in Deutschland drüber gestritten vor den Gerichten, ob das jetzt Meinungsfreiheit ist oder nicht. Das ist eine Entscheidung. Die sollen jetzt demnächst Privatpersonen innerhalb von 24 Stunden treffen. Und wie gesagt, werden dabei einen Drang dazu haben, im Zweifel lieber zu löschen, weil sie dann auf jeden Fall keine Strafe bekommen. Und deswegen ist zu erwarten, dass sie quasi ein Overblocking machen, also mehr löschen als notwendig ist. Und damit genau die Meinungsfreiheit, die ja eben an diesen Grenzen stattfindet. Für Tatsachenbehauptungen brauchen wir keine Meinungsfreiheit. Genau die wird dann da beschnitten, dadurch wie die Anreize und die Bedrohungsszenarien für die Unternehmen sind.
Ja, wir müssen nochmal sagen, vielleicht, es geht da wirklich um hohe Summen Geld. Also bis zu 50 Millionen Euro soll die Strafe betragen, steht in diesem Gesetzentwurf im Moment drin. Und ja, da ist irgendwie evident, dass dann die Netzwerke vielleicht eher sagen, bevor wir das Risiko eingehen, ja, löschen wir vielleicht eher was schneller. Ein anderes Problem, habe ich noch gelesen, ist ja auch irgendwie, das mal angenommen, ich fühle mich jetzt beleidigt von irgendjemandem. Und das hat Susi361 geschrieben und ich möchte mich gerne beschweren bei Susi361. Stimmt es, dass ich mich laut diesem Gesetzentwurf dann erkundigen kann und das Netzwerk verpflichtet ist, mir zu sagen, wer Susi361 ist, damit ich bei der mal vorbeigehen kann zu Hause?
Das ist ein selten berichteter, aber auch ein Fakt, dass man eben vereinfacht und ohne Richtervorbehalt so Feststellungen machen kann, wer also eine Person ist. Das wäre dann irgendwie bei Susi368 so ein Fall, aber das kann es natürlich auch beliebig weiterspinnen zu irgendwelchen politischen Gegnern, die dir nicht gefallen. Oder wenn du jetzt in so einem Bewertungsportal bist und da bewertet ein Patient einen Arzt negativ, dann könnte der Arzt quasi sich überlegen, wer das ist. Und überall wo du solche kostenlosen Auskunftsansprüche hast, ohne dass es ein großartiger juristischer Störfaktor ist, der das Ganze verlangsamt und prüft, das öffnet dann immer so Abmahnindustrie Tür und Tor. Also genau dieses automatisiert mal eben Fragen, Adresse rausfinden, Brief hinschicken. Das ist ja was, was wir auch so bei File-Sharing-Abmahnungen haben, wo im Prinzip Leute ein Perl-Skript und einen Drucker haben und damit eben die ganze Zeit Haushalte jeweils um die 1000 Euro erleichtern. Also auch das wird sie echt nicht haben.
Also das Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz, der Name ist toll, der Rest nicht so. Das sagen sehr viele Menschen, auch Leute, die zur Bundesregierung gehören, der ja auch Heiko Maas angehört und viele Organisationen, nicht Regierungsorganisationen sowieso. Linus Neumann vom Chaos Computer Club hat kurz zusammengefasst, was so die größten Probleme an dem Ganzen sind. Noch ist es nicht Gesetz, es ist auf dem Weg und es gibt Menschen, die das gerne schon, vor allem Heiko Maas, gerne schnell durchgepeitscht sehen würden, denn die Sommerpause naht. Ob es dazu kommen wird, ist noch nicht raus. Es kann sein, dass das wirklich so lange blockiert wird, bis ja die Wahl ansteht und dann eine neue Regierung möglicherweise dann doch wieder was ganz anderes macht. Aber dieser Gesetzentwurf wird gerade diskutiert. Gerne. Und wir schalten noch jetzt, oder du gibst quasi das Mikrofon weiter auf der Gulasch Programmier nach den Karlsruhen, wo ihr gerade beide seid. Wir schalten noch zu Starbuck, ebenfalls Chaos Computer Club Mitglied und seines Zeichens Biometrie-Forscher. Denn es gab eine Meldung diese Woche, die von euch kam, die ebenfalls für einiges Aufsehen gesorgt hat. Starbuck, der hat schon den Fingerabdrucksensor vom iPhone überlistet. Habt ihr vielleicht mitbekommen, die Meldung ist schon ein paar Jahre alt. Und diese Woche kam raus, der Iris-Sensor vom Samsung Galaxy S8. Auch der ist nicht sicher. Auch dieses biometrische Verfahren, um sich am Handy anzumelden. Also ich mach mein Handy an und die Kamera von meinem Handy scannt meine Iris und sagt, das ist Konrad, der darf jetzt ins Handy rein. Auch dieses biometrische Authentifizierungsverfahren, das ist nicht sicher. Wie hast du es geschafft, Starbuck, dieses Ding zu überlisten?
Na ja, im einfachsten Fall war es tatsächlich nur ein Ausdruck von der Iris. Also jetzt bleiben wir bei einem Beispiel, das ist dein Telefon. Stelle ich mich halt irgendwie ein paar Meter von dir weg, mach ein Foto von deinem Auge, druck das aus. Lustigerweise hatten wir irgendwie die besten Ergebnisse mit dem Samsung Drucker, der Fun-Effekt dabei. Und das Besondere, was halt bei den anderen Systemen, die ich bisher vorher getestet hab, was halt hier zusätzlich passieren muss, ist, dass man halt auf den Ausdruck noch eine Kontaktlinse rauflegen muss. Also sozusagen, um das Auge noch mehr nachzubilden, halt noch diese Krümmung von der Kontaktlinse auf den Ausdruck rauslegen. Und dann war es tatsächlich nur noch Ausdruck, Kontaktlinse rauflegen, vor das Telefon halten und das war's gewesen.
Also nur eine auf Papier gedruckte Iris reicht nicht aus. Da ist das Samsung-Telefon schlauer. Aber sobald man dann so tut, als wäre das irgendwie, hätte es diese Rundung, die ein Auge halt hat, indem man eine Kontaktlinse draufpackt, denkt sich das iPhone tatsächlich, das Samsung Galaxy S8-Telefon, denkt sich tatsächlich, das ist der Mensch, dessen Iris ich mir hier eingespeichert habe. Und da hast du tatsächlich, also es ist ja auch irgendwie ein Szenario, was man erst mal herstellen muss, dass jemand ein Foto hat von einer Iris, was ausreichende Auflösungen hat. Du hast dann tatsächlich jemanden fotografiert aus einer Entfernung, wo man das mal eben heimlich tun könnte von irgendjemandem auf der Straße?
Also ich habe das natürlich irgendwie am meisten Iris erstmal ausprobiert, weil irgendwie ist es halt einfacher zum testen. Aber wir haben ja auch schon vorher Tests gemacht. Und bei der Iris-Sache, also gerade so diese Abschätzung, wie weit man weg sein muss, da gibt es halt so Richtlinien, die sagen, du musst mindestens 70 Pixel Durchmesser der Iris haben, damit das irgendwie noch gut funktioniert. Und dann kannst du dir einfach mal eine Spielreflex-Kamera und ein Zoom-Objektiv daran hängen. Und dann kannst du halt irgendwie sehen, dass du bei so bis 5, 6 Metern kriegst du da auf jeden Fall irgendwie noch ein Bild, wo die Iris halt 70 Pixel oder mehr ist. Das heißt, wenn du da 5 Meter weg bist, hast du auf jeden Fall ein sicheres, gutes Iris-Bild, um irgendwie den Hack durchzuführen.
Also, wer ein bisschen Aufwand treibt, kann euer Samsung Galaxy S8 entsperren, nur indem er ein Foto und eine Kontaktlinse benutzt und muss nicht ihr selber sein. Das heißt jetzt, Starbuck, dass wir in der Praxis wieder ein Pin-Code nutzen sollten.
Naja, auch bei Pin-Codes ist ja so, da gibt es halt auch die verschiedenen Möglichkeiten, rauszufinden, was du gerade eintippst. Ich meine, der einfachste Fall ist, du hast auch eine Kamera und sitzt halt 5 Meter weit.
Ja, und was mache ich dann?
Tatsächlich kommen wir da zu einem Punkt, wo es schwierig wird.
Ich höre, wir müssen dann ein ganzes Chaosradio zu machen irgendwann.
Also Kombination ist natürlich immer gut, weil dann muss man halt mehrere Sachen überwinden, was halt irgendwie den Aufwand höher macht. Und ansonsten, also Passworte sind halt schon okay. Du musst halt dann wirklich aufpassen, wo du sie eintippst, oder dass es irgendwie keinen Zugriff beim Eintippen. Also die ganze Biometriesache, da wird es halt schon schwieriger, weil halt biometrische Merkmale hinterlässt man erstens überall. Das heißt irgendwie, da ist auch irgendwie, also Iris muss mal ein Foto machen oder nimmt sich halt ein Foto von deiner Facebook-Page, im einfachsten Fall. Fingerabdrücke, klaut man dir halt irgendwie die Bierflasche, die du gerade irgendwie in der Hand hattest. Von daher ist Biometrie halt schwierig, solange man die Merkmale nachmachen kann. Und das ist bei den meisten Systemen derzeit wirklich noch mit relativ geringen Aufwand möglich.
Sagt Biometrieforscher Starbuck, Mitglied vom Chaos Computer Club, auch dir vielen Dank. Wir haben über nicht so schöne Sachen geredet jetzt bisher in der Sendung. Und ich fürchte, es geht nicht so schön weiter. Also, grüße noch mal zur Gulag-Programmier-Nacht nach Karlsruhe. Und jetzt legen wir quasi los mit dem regulären Chaos Radio, mit dem, was hier im Fritz-Studio passiert. Ich darf euch zuallererst meine Gäste vorstellen. Vom Chaos Computer Club in Berlin sind heute Abend zu Gast. Und ich würde euch bitten, wir machen die Runde jetzt einmal ausführlich durch, dass ihr einmal auch kurz sagt, ich habe ja schon gesagt, wir reden heute Abend über WannaCry, der Name eines Trojaners, der vor knapp zwei Wochen ordentlich aufsehen erregt hat, denn er hat über 200.000, ja teilweise auch von 300.000 betroffenen Rechnern weltweit, über 90 Länder sollen es sein, wo diese Rechner stehen, befallen, in kürzester Zeit. Also ein Trojaner-Angriff von einem Ausmaß, was man sich bis dahin kaum vorstellen konnte oder was zumindest noch nicht so passiert ist. Und darüber rede ich mit drei Menschen und ich würde dich bitten, Danimo, der zu meiner Linken steht, einmal kurz nachdem du Hallo gesagt hast, zu sagen, warum du heute da bist, warum du mit mir, mit uns über WannaCry sprichst.
So, guten Abend erstmal.
Hallo.
Ich bin hier, weil ich das Thema angeleiert habe, denn wir finden, da gibt es ganz doll Gesprächsbedarf, ich selber hab das, hab diesen Trojaner eigentlich auch nur verfolgt, weil er auf einmal da war. Ich selber bin Administrator von verschiedenen Systemen, die es Gott sei Dank allesamt nicht getroffen hat. Aber da es dann so stark überall anders aufgetreten ist, hab ich mal angefangen, mir so ein bisschen anzugucken, quasi was jenseits der Medien denn sich hinter diesem Phänomen verbirgt, dass jetzt irgendwie anders ist als andere Krypto-Trojaner. Und bin auf der Ebenen quasi darauf hängen geblieben.
So solche Worte wie Krypto-Trojaner erklären wir gleich noch.
Das erklären wir gleich noch.
Sag mal kurz, dass es deine Systeme nicht erwischt hat, lag das daran, dass du sehr gut vorbereitet warst oder war es einfach Zufall?
Das war schon so, dass unsere Systeme einfach gepatcht waren. Also wir hatten alle Updates drauf und wir hatten tatsächlich auch aktuelle Windows-Versionen, das ist ein Luxus, den man sich allerdings, werden wir gleich auch noch besprechen, leider nicht unbedingt immer leisten kann.
Genau, also wie es passieren kann, dass das Ding bei euch zuhause auf dem Rechner landet, was hoffentlich nicht passiert ist. Ich hoffe, wenn jemand tatsächlich so ein Ding bei sich hatte, ruft voll gerne an unter 0331 70 97 110 und erzählt davon. Ich hoffe erst mal, es hat von euch hoffentlich keinen Abisch. Wir machen weiter in der Runde zuerst. Peter ist da, grüß dich.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Warum bist du bei uns? Was verbindet dich mit WannaCry?
Ja, so ähnlich wie bei Danimo habe ich von diesem Trojaner viel gehört, gesehen und fand ihn auch interessant. Ich habe selber keine Windows-Systeme und bin deswegen auch nicht betroffen. Aber ich finde ihn interessant auf jeden Fall.
Jetzt müssen wir dazu sagen, diese beiden Menschen, die sagen, sie sind hier, weil sie den Trojaner interessant finden. Es ist was anderes, als wenn ich sage, ich finde den Trojaner interessant. Wenn ich das sage, dann finde ich ihn interessant und klick mich mal durch, dass hier sind Menschen, die kennen sich halt aus und die können deswegen gleich sehr schön erklären, was da alles dahinter steckt. Der dritte im Bunde ist Alex. Alex, warum bist du hier?
Ja, ich beschäftige mich halt auch sehr gerne mit Malware, sowohl in meiner Freizeit, als eben auch dann beruflich. Mich hat es glücklicherweise auch nicht erwischt, das heißt, da waren wir drei hier bestens vorbereitet.
Sehr gut, ich würde gerne ganz tief unten anfangen, also mal richtig die Basics klären. Es fängt für mich schon an bei diesem Wort Trojaner. Es kennen ja irgendwie alle, weil es ist immer mal in Nachrichten, es gibt immer mal irgendwelche Angriffe, es gibt den Staatstrojaner zum Beispiel, über den ja auch immer mal geredet wird. Es gibt irgendwelche Softwares, die böse sind und die nennt man Trojaner. Oder was ist ein Trojaner?
Gut, man kann halt allgemein Malware in verschiedene Kategorien klassifizieren.
Okay, warte, warte. Malware ist?
Das ist allgemein Software, die jetzt Sachen tut, die als malicious, also bösartig, klassifiziert wird. Also die du nicht haben willst. Genau.
Also Malware ist die große Familie von Softwares, die ich nicht möchte.
Genau, richtig.
Gut. Und Trojaner ist ein Mitglied der Familie.
Ja, Trojaner ist auch so ein bisschen unscharves Wort. Das sagt man eigentlich zu sehr viel Software, die irgendwie etwas auf einem Computersystem tut, was es da eigentlich nicht tun soll direkt.
Also es bleibt eigentlich in diesem klassischen Bild des Trojanerischen Pferdes, wo sich etwas drin versteckt. Aber was dann passiert, was die Motivation ist, also beim klassischen Trojaner ist ja klar, da war das ein Heer. Und dahinter stand nichts anderes als eine Stadt zu erobern. Aber die Motivation bei einem Trojaner auf einem Rechner, was der tut, was der versteckt und wer da aus welchen Motivationen was tut, ist sehr unterschiedlich. Und auch die Schäden, die so ein Trojaner anrichten kann, ist unterschiedlich. Das fängt an bei tut einfach Sachen ohne, dass du es je bemerkst, kann aber auch bis zu solchen sehr offensichtlichen Sachen wie WannaCry gehen, wo deine Festplatte verschlüsselt wird.
Genau, das wäre noch ein Sonderfall. Aber lass mich kurz noch einmal fürs Verständnis. Trojaner, wenn ich das höre, dann gehe ich richtig, wenn ich mir vorstelle, es ist eine Software, die sich auf meinen Rechner schleicht, um etwas zu tun, was sie nicht vorgibt, zu tun, aber dann tut. Und das ist meistens böse. Und jetzt hast du gerade schon gesagt, was der WannaCry-Trojaner gemacht hat. Das war was Spezielles. Du hast vorhin schon das Wort Kryptotrojaner benutzt. Was hat der getan?
Der hat sich tatsächlich noch nicht mal als Erster. Es gab da auch schon andere Trojaner, die sich da hervorgetan haben. Aber der fällt in diese Familie von diesen sogenannten Kryptotrojanern. Kryptotrojaner bedeutet nichts anderes als Krypto. Kennen wir vielleicht einen Krypto-Messenger. Das heißt, damit verbinden wir die Hoffnung, dass wir für Schlüssel sicher kommunizieren können, dass kann keiner entschlüsseln. Und endlich funktioniert auch so ein Trojaner. Der fängt nämlich an, die Dateien auf der Festplatte zu verschlüsseln. Nur, dass er mir den Schlüssel nicht dalässt. Das bedeutet, wenn ich dann anschließend da ran will, dann werde ich von einem freundlichen Fenster auf dem Bildschirm aufgeklärt. Schicken sie doch bitte Bezahlungen so und so auf diesem Wege dort und dorthin. Und dann erhalten sie den Schlüssel, mit dem sie wieder an ihre Daten rankommen, die sie im Zweifelsfall nicht geweckt gehabt haben.
Wenn ihr das Wort Ransomware mal gehört habt, das ist genau das.
Genau, Ransom-Erpressung.
Also ein anderer Begriff für diese Kryptotrojaner. Lief dann in dem Fall so, glaube ich. Also ich möchte kurz anmerken, diese Hacker haben einiges geschafft. Sie haben haufenweise Rechner infiziert. Was sie nicht können, ist Ästhetik.
Ja, da gab es auch dieses Mem von irgendeinem Designer, der da nichts besseres zu tun hatte als den Leuten, die gerade all ihre Daten potenziell verloren haben oder zumindest nur wieder kriegen, wenn sie relativ viel Geld bezahlen. Zu sagen, ja, wisst ihr was, ist ja alles irgendwie schön und gut, aber das sieht ja ästhetisch so kacke aus. Also hier zwei Pixel runter und hier bitte Grid Alignment. Ja, das ist fies. Aber ich fürchte, der meinte das auch so ein bisschen ernst.
Ja, also ihr habt es vielleicht gesehen, diese Bilder gehen ja auch um die Screenshots davon. Es ist ein größtenteils rotes Fenster, wo so ein Text in der Mitte ist, in dem drin steht sinngemäß Hallo, wir haben Ihre Daten verschlüsselt. Wenn Sie Ihre Daten wieder haben möchten, dann bezahlen Sie diese Summe in Bitcoin auf dieses Konto. Bitcoin, die Kryptowährung im Netz, mit der man bezahlen kann an Menschen, ohne zu wissen, welcher Mensch dahinter steht, an wen man bezahlt. Also ein relativ sicherer Weg auch für so Hacker, sich bezahlen zu lassen. Und dann waren quasi die Gelackmaierten die Kunden von diesen Hackern. Ich glaube, so wurden sie auch genannt teilweise.
Naja, also die Hacker verstehen sich tatsächlich auch als Leute, die, sagen wir, diese Leute, die sind Koerner, die Erpresser. Letztendlich muss man sagen Erpresser. Das sind auch professionelle Banden. Und die verstehen sich, sind halt mafiöse Strukturen. Und die verstehen sich auch tatsächlich so, dass sie Kundenservice anbieten. Wenn jemand sagt, ich kriege das hier nicht auf die Kette, erklär doch mal, dann leisten die also auch durchaus Kundenservice. Es ist ja sogar in deren Interesse, dass das Geld bei ihnen ankommt. Und jemand, der nicht zahlt, weil er irgendwann aufgeht, sagt vielleicht so wichtig waren die Daten vielleicht doch nicht. Also die tun tatsächlich gut daran, das zu machen. Und was auch aufgefallen ist, also was mir persönlich aufgefallen ist bei WannaCry, das war einer der ersten, die ich gesehen habe, die mit größtenteils wirklich wirklich guten Übersetzungen kamen. Zumindest die deutsche Variante war definitiv nicht nur ein Google Translate.
Also es haben dann einige Menschen Geld überwiesen. Ist klar, wie viel das waren?
Ich hab die Zahl 40.000 US-Dollar gesehen.
So viele sind überwiesen worden.
Du hast ja gesagt, es ist relativ sicher, aber es ist eben nur pseudonym. Das heißt, man weiß nicht, wer dahinter steht. Aber man kann, dass ja gerade die Stärke von Bitcoin sogar sehr genau nachverfolgen, welche Transaktionen, welche Höhe passieren in diesem Netzwerk. Das ist also tatsächlich ein Netzwerk von Transaktionen, das in einem ewigen Logbuch steht und nachvollziehbar ist.
Ja, die haben einen öffentlichen Logbuch.
Und zwar öffentlich. Und das bedeutet, man kann also sehen, an welche sogenannten Wallets, so nennt sich das Geldbörsen, da dann Geld überwiesen wurde. Man konnte also verfolgen, wie erfolgreich oder eben auch nicht es war. Und also mit 40.000, muss man sagen, war es vergleichsweise wenig erfolgreich.
Ja, vor allem dafür, wie viele Rechner infiziert waren.
Genau, aber es gab, es war halt auch nicht die erste Attacke. Und ich glaube, die Leute unter Umständen beginnen sie zu lernen, sodass das, was verloren gegangen ist, im Zweifelsfall nicht so wichtig war.
Ja genau, also was zu tun ist, wenn sowas passiert, welche Chance es gibt, die Daten zurückzubekommen. Wir lassen uns darüber vielleicht später noch sprechen. Aber ist euch ein Fall bekannt, wo es geklappt hat? Also gibt es, ist irgendein Fall offiziell geworden, wo jemand bezahlt hat an diese Macher von WannaCry und tatsächlich die Daten zurückbekommen hat?
Im Fall von WannaCry? Ich nicht, aber bei anderen Trojanern habe ich glaubhafte Geschichten, wo es dann tatsächlich hieß, ich brauche diese Daten wieder.
Aber WannaCry tatsächlich nicht?
Ich nicht, nein.
Da ist tatsächlich bisher sehr wenig öffentlich bekannt geworden, ob da jetzt Leute bezahlt haben. Da gibt es gerade auch noch Diskussionen, wie gut denn der Kundensupport in diesem Fall überhaupt ist. Also da scheint der Branchenstandard eher nicht eingehalten worden zu sein.
Okay, also 40.000 US-Dollar sind geflossen und wahrscheinlich sind sie komplett umsonst geflossen von Menschen, die verzweifelt gedacht haben, oh Mann, ich habe keinen Backup und ich brauche dringend meine Daten zurück. Wie das alles vonstatten gehen konnte, wie es funktioniert hat, dass dieser Trojaner auf irgendwelchen Haufenweise Rechnern landen konnte, wie er das angestellt hat, das klären wir gleich. Wir machen kurz vor den Nachrichten. Hier ist das Chaos Radio im Blue Moon auf Fritz.
Und eine Band mit Hand zum poppigen Pop. Wenn ihr jetzt denkt, das wären drei verschiedene Bands... Linkin Park, live in der Bands Arena. Ihr einziges Solo-Konzert in Deutschland.
So lange es noch Karten gibt... Gibt es Karten überall, wo es Karten gibt.
Und wenn ihr Tickets dafür gewinnen wollt...
Einfach gut Fritz hören.
Linkin Park, live in Berlin.
Von und mit Merlin Schulz.
Die Menschen sollen sich gegen Fremdenhass und Nationalismus einsetzen. Das hat der ehemalige US-Präsident Obama beim Evangelischen Kirchentag in Berlin gesagt. Bei einer Diskussionsrunde am Brandenburger Tor, an der auch Bundeskanzlerin Merkel teilnahm, sagte er, man müsse sich hinter demokratische Werte stellen und gegen die eintreten, die diese Werte zurückdrängen wollten. Merkel sagte, die deutsche Asylpolitik müsse sich auf die Menschen in der Welt konzentrieren, die dringend Hilfe brauchen. Der von US-Präsident Trump angeordnete Einreisestopp für Menschen aus sechs muslimischen Ländern bleibt weiter verboten. Das hat ein Berufungsgericht im US-Bundesstaat Virginia entschieden, wie heute bekannt wurde. Damit bestätigte das Berufungsgericht ein erstes Urteil aus dem Bundesstaat Maryland. Das Weiße Haus hatte den Einreisestopp mit der nationalen Sicherheit begründet, daran zweifelten die Richter. US-Präsident Trump war bereits mit einem ersten Einreisestopp gescheitert, darin ging es noch um sieben muslimische Länder. Der frühere griechische Ministerpräsident Papademos ist durch eine Explosion verletzt worden. Nach Angaben der Polizei explodierte ein Sprengsatz im Auto, versteckt in einem Briefumschlag. Papademos und auch sein Fahrer werden im Krankenhaus behandelt, sie schweben aber nicht in Lebensgefahr. Papademos war 2011 und 2012 Regierungschef in Griechenland. In der Relegation für die 1. Fußball-Bundesliga hat Wolfsburg das Hinspiel gegen Braunschweig gewonnen. Die Partie endete 1 zu 0. Das Rückspiel findet am Montag in Braunschweig statt. Dann entscheidet sich, ob in der nächsten Saison Wolfsburg oder Braunschweig in der 1. Liga spielt. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Berlin-Matzahn 15°C, Charlottenburg 16°C, Prenzlau 13°C, Forst 14°C, Falkensee und Brück 16°C. Bis in die Nacht bleibt es trocken und teils bewölkt. In der Nacht sinkt das Thermometer bis auf 7°C. Der Freitag startet bewölkt, es bleibt aber meist trocken. Im Laufe des Tages lässt sich dann auch die Sonne blicken bei Höchstwerten von 22°C in Berlin und 24°C in Brandenburg. Stadtverkehr Berlin. In Tiergarten und Mitte gibt es wegen des Kirchentags noch bis in die Nacht zahlreiche Sperrungen zwischen Siegessäule und Gendarmemarkt. Umfahrt diesen Bereich bitte weiträumig oder nutzt öffentliche Verkehrsmittel. Es fahren zusätzliche U- und S-Bahn. Der 100er-Bus fährt bis Betriebsschuss in diesem Abschnitt nicht. Auch die Buslinie TXL zum Flughafentegel ist zwischen Alexanderplatz und Hauptbahnhof unterbrochen. Allen unterwegs, eine gute Fahrt.
Dankeschön.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB. Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz-Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an.
Die Playlist auf fritz.de. Und das Auge hört mit, man.
Fritz. Seid gegrüßt, Konrad Spremberg ist hier und außerdem drei Menschen vom Chaos Computer Club. Denn heute Abend ist Chaos Radio im Blue Moon auf Fritz Danimus da. Peter ist da. Alex ist auch da. Und wir reden über WannaCry. Kurze Zusammenfassung, was wir schon haben. Also es gab vor knapp zwei Wochen diesen riesigen Angriff von Erpressern, die sich mit einem Trojaner auf hunderttausende Rechner auf der ganzen Welt geschlichen haben. Sie haben diesen Menschen eine Software aufgespielt, die alle Daten, die auf diesen Rechnern waren, verschlüsselt haben, sodass sie nicht mehr zugreifbar waren für die Besitzer. Also stellt euch vor, ihr habt einen Rechner und habt aber keinen Zugriff mehr auf eure Daten, weil die leider verschlüsselt sind und ihr das Passwort nicht habt. So war das. Und dann wird euch auf eurem Bildschirm einen Hinweis angezeigt. Hallo, sie können ihre Daten wiederbekommen, wenn sie uns bezahlen. Und dann musste man Bitcoins überweisen. Wie viel waren es?
Entsprechend 300 US-Dollar.
300 US-Dollar.
Hingen auch vom Land ab tatsächlich. Also das war eine ganz interessante Sache, kann man vielleicht mal kurz erzählen. Die haben den sogenannten Big Mac Index hergenommen. Das ist ein Index, der erstellt wird, um zu gucken, wie viel Geld man aufwenden muss, um einen Big Mac zu erstehen. Und dementsprechend musste man halt Poland mehr oder weniger bezahlen. Weil es gab halt, in anderen Fällen haben sich Gruppen halt an gerade etwas ärmeren Nationen versucht und da war dann der Ransom, also die Lösegeldsumme, so hoch, dass sie dann auch gesagt haben, wir sehen einen, das war vielleicht ein bisschen viel, hier habt ihr den Entschlüsselungs-Key für lau.
Ja krass, ein weiteres Beispiel, dass die Macher von WannaCry sich sehr viele Gedanken gemacht haben vorher, wie sie vorgehen sollen und dann tatsächlich sogar, ja sie müssen ja so irgendwie so einen Mittelwert gefunden haben von einer Summe, die ist man vielleicht bereit zu bezahlen, wenn einem die Daten heilig sind. Und sie ist aber auch nicht so niedrig, dass es sich gar nicht lohnt. Eigentlich ganz, also ich will nicht sagen cool, aber schon irgendwie gut durchdacht das Ganze.
Also das ist halt das, was ich mit mafiösen Strukturen meine. Das ist wie ein Wirtschaftsbetrieb, nur halt mit richtig, richtig illegalen Mitteln.
Ja, wir haben gerade schon geklärt, was ein Trojaner ist, was ein Krypto-Trojaner ist, was man auch Ransomware nennt, also ein Erpressungstrojaner. Wenn ihr das noch nachhören wollt, wenn ihr es verpasst habt, ihr könnt nach der Sendung den Podcast komplett hören auf fritz.de. Da gibt es alles, was wir hier an Super Basics gerade eben besprochen haben, nochmal zum Nachhören. Ihr könnt auch übrigens zugucken, was wir hier gerade machen. Es gibt im Netz von euch ein Video-Stream.
Genau, schaut einfach nach auf streaming.media.ccc.de und dort, wenn wir dann hier durch sind, könnt ihr nahtlos weitergucken. Die Videos von der Gulasch Programmier-Nacht, zum Beispiel der Starbuck, der hier gerade Rede und Antwort gestellt hat, der hat einen Vortrag gehalten, der steht jetzt schon online. Den könnt ihr euch danach gerne reinziehen.
streaming.media.ccc.de, lange Nummer. So, lass uns weiter sprechen darüber, wie es WannaCry geschafft hat, all diese Rechner zu infizieren. Ich nehme mal an, es muss in irgendeiner Form auf diesen Rechnern Türen gegeben haben, durch die WannaCry hineinschreiten konnte, oder?
Letztendlich sind das Programmierfehler, die in diesem Fall in Windows-Systemen drin waren und wahrscheinlich auch in vielen Fällen immer noch sind, die ausgenutzt werden konnten und dazu geführt haben, dass die Angreifer oder die Erpresser eine beliebige Software ausführen konnten auf den Systemen.
Wie kann ich mir das vorstellen? Programmierfehler, was bedeutet das?
Das bedeutet, dass der Entwickler, also einer oder viele Programmierer, bei Microsoft, die haben sich etwas ausgedacht und haben versucht, das auch genauso zu implementieren, zu programmieren, wie sie sich das ausgedacht haben. Aber die haben da etwas übersehen, an einer Ecke oder vielleicht an mehreren. Und wenn man als Programmierer eben Fälle übersieht, führt das zu unerwarteter oder unerwünschter...
Also, ich glaube, am einfachsten lässt sich das mit einem Trickbetrug vergleichen in der normalen Welt. Also, in der normalen Welt, wenn normalerweise jemand im Blaumann vor dir vor der Tür steht und sagt, ich muss mal gerade hier die Heizung ablesen, das kann jemand von den Stadtwerken sein, das kann aber auch ein Gauner sein, der so tut, als wäre er das. Und dir dann im Zweifelsfall, gerade wenn man älterer Person ist, die Geldbörse klaut und einmal sich durch das Hab und Gut wehlös.
Und wenn ich vergesse, mir seinen Ausweis zeigen zu lassen, habe ich einen Programmierfehler?
Genau.
Okay, also ich bin der Rechner und bekomme Besuch und merke nicht, dass der Besuch böse ist.
So ist das gelaufen quasi.
Genau.
Und das Wort exploit, was man oft liest im Moment in den Nachrichten, ist dafür der Fachbegriff?
Gut, exploit, halt ausnutzen. Also das ist dann im Prinzip der Begriff dafür, dass man dann eben so einen Programmierfehler nutzt und dann halt Kontrolle über eben das gegenüberliegende System. Das kann dann ein Programm sein oder eben auch unter Umständen dann direkt das Betriebssystem, um das eben zu bekommen. Und das war in diesem Fall dann tatsächlich auch das Besondere an diesem WannaCry, dass eben nicht über die typischen Verbreitungswege von eben Malware, also E-Mail größtenteils.
Also oft läuft so, ich bekomme eine Mail, da ist ein Anhang drin, ich klick drauf, weil ich denke, der ist vertrauenswürdig, oder weil ich einfach nicht denke. Und darüber kann die Software mein Computer befallen.
Genau. Wenn es eine gut gemachte Ransomware ist, dann gibt es vielleicht noch irgendeinen Visual Basic, irgendein Skript, was mitkommt oder irgendein kleines Tool, was dann vielleicht nochmal das Adressbuch liest und an alle Kontakte in der eigenen Kontaktliste weiter verschickt oder so. Das heißt, es gibt unter Umständen schon so einen Selbstverbreitungsmechanismus, aber typischerweise eher selten über wirklich Exploits.
Wer war das? Wer hat WannaCry gemacht und verteilt?
Kann man nicht sagen.
Das ist sehr, sehr schwierig. Es haben verschiedene Antivirenhersteller. Das sind ja die, die neben Software verkaufen, sich auch in der Analyse von komplexeren Angriffsszenarien versuchen. Die haben eine Attributierung versucht. Also die haben versucht, jemandem das zuzuschreiben aufgrund von Verhaltensweisen. Und ich glaube, die aktuelle Theorie, die gerade immer noch durch die Netze und durch die Medien geistert ist, dass es angeblich die Nordkoreaner waren, also zumindest auftragsmäßig jemanden bezahlt haben, also eine Gruppe, die das dann macht.
Also nordkoreanische, mit der Regierung verbundene Leute?
Genau, es kann auch einfach im Auftrag gewesen sein. Also man hat sich da versucht auf Muster, auf gewisse Software, die eingesetzt wurde, die auch in anderen Fällen eingesetzt wird von derselben Gruppe, wo man damals auch der Meinung war, das müsste im Auftrag von Nordkorea gewesen sein. Und das ist, du hörst es schon, ziemlich viel müsste, könnte, sollte und es gibt ja auch viel absichtlich falsche Attributierung, dass man sich irgendwie von einer anderen Gruppe, Software, die die übrig gelassen haben bei einem Angriff extra nimmt oder sich so gebiert und genau die nachmacht, eben damit es so aussieht, als wäre es jemand anderes gewesen. Attributierung ist de facto nicht möglich und ganz ehrlich, wenn du mich fragst, das kann genauso gut wieder eine 0815 Mafia-Bande gewesen sein, die einfach Kohle abgreifen wollte.
Und ein bisschen in IT investiert haben.
Genau.
Aber krass, weil es ist ja was Neues. Also es gab ja das in diesem Umfang noch nicht bisher.
Naja, ich bin ja der Meinung, das gab es halt schon. Der einzige wirkliche Unterschied ist ja, es musste niemand eine E-Mail anklicken.
Ja, genau, lass uns mal kurz darüber sprechen. Also ihr habt gesagt, es war in dem Fall nicht. Gar nicht. Und zum Teil diese E-Mail-Nummer. Es ging vor allem auf anderem Wege. Gar nicht. Wie ging es dann?
Das war eben einer dieser vorhin erläuterten Bugs. Also eben in diesem Fall besonders schlimm. Direkt im Betriebssystem selber, in Windows, in einer der wirklich Kernkomponenten, gab es eben einen Programmierfehler, den man eben ausnutzen kann, um Remote, also ohne direkten Zug auf das System zu haben, sondern rein über das Netzwerk, über das Internet, eben konnte man diese Schwachstelle ausnutzen, um eben Code auf dem anderen System auszuführen. Und dieser Bug mit dem dazugehörigen Exploit, also dem Tool, um das dann wirklich auszunutzen, wurde dann eben benutzt oder wird benutzt, um WannaCry auf Systeme zu bringen.
Aber wie kommt WannaCry von einem System zum anderen?
Im Wesentlichen, wenn ich mich jetzt als Person in einem Unternehmen infiziere, dann schaut dieser Krypto-Trojaner im lokalen Netzen nach anderen Systemen, die eben dieses verwundbare Windows-Komponente haben und verbreiten sich eben dann über diesen Weg. Zusätzlich gibt es noch einen zweiten Verbreitungsmechanismus. Das ist im Wesentlichen so ein Remote Desktop Enumeration. Also wenn ich jetzt hingehe, mich über diese Remote-Wartungsfunktion in Windows bei RDP auf ein anderes System einlogge, dann kann diese Malware das mit ganz normalen Windows-Boardmitteln nutzen, um diesen quasi offenen Kanal zu nutzen, um sich darüber dann auch weiter zu verbreiten.
Also wenn zum Beispiel ihr von eurer Firma oder was auch immer so eine Zuhause-Wartung bekommt, dass irgendein Admin sich in euren Rechner reinschleicht, aber erwünscht reinschleicht und dann Sachen machen kann, das ist ein Weg, über den auch der Trojaner eingespielt wurde.
Genau, das ist halt eine übliche Funktion, um halt jetzt zum Beispiel in einem größeren Netzwerk dann einzelne Server zu warten, dass man sich dann eben darauf einloggt und da dann eben was auch immer man gerade tun möchte tut. Und wenn ich jetzt auf meinem Administrationsrechner, im schlimmsten Fall jetzt mein Administrationslaptop, selber schon diese Ransomware hab und die jetzt an diesem Punkt dann schaut, ok, was habe ich denn gerade für offene Verbindung, dann geht ihr eben hin und verbreitet sich selber über diese offenen Kanäle auf die anderen Rechner.
Aber du hast gerade gesagt, es muss sich erstmal jemand in der Firma, in dem Netzwerk infizieren, um dann die anderen zu infizieren. Wie kommt der Virus denn zu diesem ersten Menschen?
Genau, dieser initiale Verbreitungsweg, also wie das wirklich dann angefangen hat, da deutet gerade eigentlich alles darauf hin, dass Leute ungepatchte Systeme, die also verwundbar gegen diesen Exploiter benutzt wird, sind frei im Internet haben. Also ohne Firewall und mit einer öffentlichen IP, sodass die eben direkt erreichbar sind.
Und zwar ausreichend viele, dass da so viele Rechner auf der ganzen Welt infiziert werden konnten, von denen aus dann wieder andere infiziert werden konnten. Und deswegen hat sich dieser Trojaner so unfassbar schnell verbreiten können.
Genau, und da haben sie halt die, also letztendlich war auch diese Erkenntnis, dass es relativ viele Rechner gibt, die im Internet stehen und diesen sogenannten Port, also diesen Service quasi anbieten oder dort horchen Richtung Internet. Das war tatsächlich auch schon länger bekannt, da wurde auch vor gewarnt. Und zwar in dem Moment, als die Lücke veröffentlicht wurde, die dann letztendlich auch WannaCry ausgenutzt hat. Da kommen wir gleich noch drauf. Aber da wurde halt schon gesagt, oh, das ist aber schwierig, weil das betrifft ja super viele Systeme. Also es war ein bekannter Fakt, aber offensichtlich haben mehrere Tage lang die Verantwortlichen trotzdem nicht reagiert. Möglicherweise, weil ihnen gar nicht klar war, dass ihre Systeme das betrifft.
Also an manchen war es klar, ihr habt vielleicht mitbekommen, die Deutsche Bahn ist Opfer geworden. Da waren Anzeigetafeln kaputt, teilweise auch Fahrkartenautomaten. Es waren Autofabriken betroffen, es waren in Großbritannien mehrere Krankenhäuser, wirklich schwer betroffen, die da lebenswichtige Operationen verschieben mussten. Also halt wirklich ein Ausmaß, wo es gefährlich geworden ist. Und das meinte ich von so ein bisschen mit, das gab es bisher nicht, zumindest mir nicht, in Erinnerung, dass es schon mal in diesem Ausmaß eine erfolgreiche Verbreitung von so einem Kryptotrojaner gab.
Das mag aber auch ein bisschen an der Sichtbarkeit liegen. Wenn du jetzt so einen Bahnkartenautomaten oder gerade so Anzeigen, die ja wirklich im Bahnhof dann mehrfach angezeigt werden, wenn du das dann siehst, dann ist das halt viel präsenter, als wenn das nur ein paar arme Seelen in einem Krankenhaus trifft. Also Krankenhäuser sind auch schon vorher angegriffen worden. Dort scheint es aber wirklich dieses National Healthcare System, also die Infrastruktur dahinter betroffen zu haben, was es jetzt dann auch mal ein bisschen speziell schwierig gemacht hat, eben weil dieser Trojaner so schön springen kann. Nicht nur darauf sich verlassen muss, dass einzelne Arbeitsplätze angegriffen werden, weil irgendjemand halt auf so eine E-Mail geklickt hat. Dann hast du ja maximal ein System verloren.
Ich habe dann Anfang letzte Woche von einigen Menschen gelesen, die sich Sorgen gemacht haben oder auch schon am Wochenende, dass das nur der Anfang ist, dass der Code von diesem Trojaner, der dann im Netz irgendwie stand, benutzt wird von irgendwelchen Trittbrettfahrern, die diesen gleichen Angriff noch mal versuchen. Und das ist aber nicht passiert, oder?
Nee, genau. Also da ging es jetzt nicht um den Code von dem Trojaner selber direkt, sondern eben von der Komponente, die eigentlich jetzt auch am interessantesten ist, die halt benutzt wird, um andere Systeme anzugreifen. Also dieser Exploit, der eben benutzt wird, um ungepatchte Windows-Systeme anzugreifen, der ist ursprünglich gar nicht von den Angreifern, sondern der ist nämlich ursprünglich von einem Nachrichtendienst entwickelt worden und geleakt worden im Internet, sodass das eben dann jeder, der eben dieses Leak bekommen hat, frei benutzen kann, um eben andere ungepatchte Windows-Rechner anzugreifen.
Die Angreifer haben das gemacht, andere haben es scheinbar danach nicht nochmal versucht, obwohl es so gut geklappt hat.
Es ist auch immer die Frage, wenn du fragst und ob du es überhaupt merkst, weil haben es andere versucht. Das Beste, was wir sagen können, wir wissen es nicht, es gab noch mal eine Variante von diesem WannaCry. Das ging ja auch durch die Presse. Der Original WannaCry ließ sich abschalten. Das hat jemand gemacht, der eine Adresse, eine Internetadresse registriert hat, die er in dem Programmcode gefunden hat. Die war ein eingebauter Schalter, der dafür gesorgt hat, dass dieser WannaCry-Virus gesagt hat, wenn diese Adresse existiert und mir antwortet, dann mache ich es nicht. Da gibt es auch viele Spekulationen, warum das so ist. Aber Fakt ist, da hat es dann aufgehört und es gab dann wohl nochmal eine Variante, wo dieser Schalter rausgenommen wurde. Da ist die Vermutung, dass das nicht derselbe Urheber war, sondern eben ein Trittbrettfahrer, der einfach mal den Code angepasst hat. Eine zweite Komponente, die fand ich recht interessant, war, es gibt Sicherheitsforscher, die davon ausgehen und auch Beweise dafür haben, dass es Gruppen gab, die vor WannaCry diesen Bug ausgenutzt haben, in dem Moment, als diese NSA-Lücke, das war damals der Geheimdienst, der das verloren hat, als sie rauskam, dort schon in den Rechner eingestiegen sind, aber halt nicht so auffällig, deren Ziele waren halt anders. Denn Ziele waren jetzt nicht Erpressung, sondern halt Ausforschen von Unternehmen. Und das ist ja eine genau andere Zielsetzung. Da will ich eben nicht auffallen. Da will ich nicht eine fette Maske aufploppen lassen mit hier, ich bin da. Genau, wir waren da, sondern die gehen sogar so weit, dass die gar nichts auf dem System installieren. Die bleiben nur im Arbeitsspeicher. Und in dem Moment, wo ich das System runterfahre als Benutzer, ist es auch weg. Und der Eingreifer muss quasi das System bei jedem Neustart neu infizieren. Aber das machen die halt dann einfach.
Und wir wissen einfach nicht, in welchem Umfang es sowas dann gab, weil man es nicht mitbekommt.
Genau, im Zweifelsfall ist es nur sehr, sehr schwer nachzuweisen.
Jetzt gibt es ja von den Leuten, die ihr genannt habt, die in irgendeiner Weise beteiligt sind, viele von denen man sagen könnte, ey, ihr seid schuld. Zum einen die Betroffenen, die Firmen, zum Beispiel die Krankenhäuser, die irgendwie ihre Systeme nicht mit den nötigen Patches, den nötigen Updates versehen haben. Es könnte Microsoft schuld sein, die es nicht geschafft haben, rechtzeitig Lücken zu schließen. Es könnten die Geheimdienste schuld sein, von denen diese Exploits entwickelt worden sind. Wer ist schuld an dem Ganzen?
Ich finde alle von denen.
Es ist natürlich immer sehr schwierig, auf eine einzelne Instanz zu zeigen, zu sagen, okay, da sitzt jetzt der Schuldige, der genau das jetzt verbrochen hat. Das verteilt sich da natürlich so ein bisschen. Aber dass jetzt ein Geheimdienst in dem Fall eben dann, wie gerade erwähnt, die NSA hingeht und eine Sicherheitslücke in so einer essenziellen Komponente, wie eben jetzt im Windows-Könnel in dem Fall, im wirklich Betriebssystem Kern, was auch in jeder Windows-Version seit XP so ist, dieser Code halt drin, dass man so etwas dann mehrere Jahre für sich behält und eben dann auch nicht wenigstens nach einer gewissen Zeit dann direkt meldet, das ist schon sehr, sehr übel.
Man muss dazu sagen, das ist ja die zeitliche Abfolge war ja, dass eine Gruppe, deren Auftraggeber oft wieder unklar ist, nennt sich Shadowbrokers, vermutet werden die Russen, aber wer weiß das schon, die haben der NSA offensichtlich diese Tools abgejagt und haben halt gesagt, wir veröffentlichen die. Und das war also eine Ansage, dass das nach einer gewissen Zeit passieren würde. Und die NSA hat das offensichtlich so ernst genommen, dass sie Microsoft dann, als das klar wurde, dass sie also ihr Spielzeug schon verloren haben, erst dann sind sie zu Microsoft gelaufen und haben gesagt, hier, das wollt ihr vielleicht mal beheben, das Problem. Und all die Jahre vorher, und es ist ja noch in Windows XP drin, das ist jetzt fast 2003 rausgekommen, es ist schon wirklich, wirklich lange, dass es diese Sicherheitslücke gibt. Und da dann drauf zu sitzen und letztendlich nur im allerletzten Moment zu schreien, das ist einfach zu spät. Und für ältere Betriebssysteme, das ist aber jetzt auch wieder so ein Problem, wo man sich streiten kann. Stell dir vor, du hast ein Industriesystem. Du kaufst ja als Unternehmen so eine, was weiß ich, irgendeine... Robotersteuerung oder... Wir sind ja hier in einem Rundfunkstudio. Stell dir vor, du hast ja mal irgendwie hier so eine Automatisierung für einen Sendebetrieb gekauft. Der läuft halt auf XP. Und die Unternehmen sagen halt, na das ist doch noch gut. Also hier beim RBB sehe ich, haben sie das Gott sei Dank festgestellt. Nein, hier gibt es kein XP mehr. Hier läuft gutes Windows 7.
Aber war nicht sogar Windows 7 das eigentlich betroffene System?
Ja, aber es gab einen Patch-Cycle vorher. Microsoft hat nämlich seinen Patch-Day. Die machen einmal pro Monat einen Patch-Day. Der wurde verschoben. Der wurde noch nie verschoben.
Ohne weitere Erklärung?
Ohne weitere Erklärung vor allen Dingen. Nicht irgendwie, oh da ist uns was schief gegangen oder so, sondern ohne Erklärung wurde das gestrichen. Und da wurde also in der Fachpresse gemunkelt, na was ist denn da los? Und das war offensichtlich der Grund, dass sie unbedingt schnellstmöglich in diesen Zyklus, in diesen Update-Zyklus noch eine Fehlerkorrektur für diese Lücke reinkriegen wollten.
Aber sie waren zu langsam.
Nee, gar nicht mal. Man hatte tatsächlich realistisch einen Monat Zeit. Sogar etwas mehr als einen Monat. Aber die Frage ist halt, ob das in jedem Fall genug ist. Also klar für dich und mich, die wir so ein Endgerät haben, und da kommt so eine Anzeige hoch, hier Update.
Zur Fabriksteuerung oder so.
Genau, das ist kein Problem. Aber so eine Fabriksteuerung, die auf XP läuft, oder irgendeine andere Steuerung, die ich möglicherweise mitsamt Wartungsdienstleistung von einem anderen Unternehmen eingekauft habe, das dann nach eigenem Gutdünken macht. Und die halt sagen, ich spiele keine Updates ein, wer weiß, ob dann die Steuerung noch geht. Oder es gibt ja durchaus auch Zertifizierungen. Also es gibt tatsächlich Zertifizierungen, das ist sogar ganz üblich. Wenn da auch nur eine Zeile Quellcode geändert wird, dann muss diese Zertifizierung neu durchlaufen werden. Die ist teuer, die kostet Zeit und solange steht man in der Produktion unter Umständen.
Also haben so Unternehmen wie auch vielleicht diese Krankenhäuser zum Beispiel oder die Autohersteller teilweise diese vielleicht Kutsche oder zumindest aus Unternehmern sich nachvollziehbare Gründe, die Updates nicht immer sofort zu fahren?
Und das Schlimme ist, du kannst von außen nicht unterscheiden, wo ist Fahrlässigkeit im Spiel, wo sind die Prozesse einfach nur nicht richtig abgestimmt und wo gibt es tatsächlich keine gute Lösung? Das sind, glaube ich, so die drei Sachen, auf die ich das jetzt runterbrechen würde. Also ganz oft ist es tatsächlich Fahrlässigkeit. Da kenne ich sogar Fälle, die ich jetzt hier so nicht erzählen kann. Da war es wirklich einfach nicht... Also da wurde dieser Fall nicht eingeplant.
Kein Update-Server vorhanden vielleicht.
Bitte?
Kein Update-Server vorhanden.
Nee, aber da wurde einfach nicht davon ausgegangen, dass sowas passieren kann.
Oder man hat schon einen Update-Zyklus, aber der ist zu langsam, man macht nur Updates alle drei Monate, weil man erstmal ordentlich testen will, dass die neuen Updates nichts kaputt machen.
Ja, puh, ich kann es halt so ein bisschen nachvollziehen. Also so vom Gefühl her, es passiert nie was. Warum soll jetzt im nächsten Jahr was passieren? Wir haben es doch immer so gemacht und es läuft super. Naja, die Menschen wurden jetzt eines Besseren belehrt. Habt ihr das Gefühl, das wirkt schon?
Naja, aber was hat sich denn geändert für die Leute, die dieses sechs Jahre alte XP da rumstehen haben mit ihrer Industriensteuerung? Die stehen immer noch vor dem gleichen Problem. Was sie vielleicht jetzt tun, bleibt zu hoffen, ist dem Hersteller auf den Leib zu rücken. Aber der Hersteller sagt im Zweifelsfall, ja, das ist jetzt sechs Jahre her, ist aus Garantie oder aus Erwartung raus. Oder noch schlimmer, was auch sehr häufig passiert, der Hersteller ist längst insolvent. Und in dem Moment muss ich halt in Investitionen der ganzen Anlage ran. Ich glaube, die Lehre müssen Unternehmen ziehen, auch wenn sie nicht schön ist. In dem Moment, wo ich ein System anschaffe, muss beim Einkauf Kriterium sein, ist, wie lange ist der Wartungsvorwärtsfond, auch in Bezug auf Sicherheitslücken. Und kriege ich notfalls auch das Betriebssystem aktualisiert, wenn da gar nichts mehr geht.
Also es gibt, wie ihr hört, keine einfache Lösung bei dem Ganzen. Was da vielleicht politisch oder unternehmenstechnisch zu tun wäre für die Zukunft, darüber wollen wir nachher noch sprechen. Ich würde vorschlagen, wir hören ein bisschen Musik und quatschen dann weiter über WannaCry im Chaosradio im Blue Moon auf Ritz. Jetzt geht es kurz nach Frankreich zu einer Band namens Candids. Der Song heißt Summer. Summer, Musik von Candids im Chaosradio im Blue Moon auf Fritz. 23 Uhr haben wir's. Nee, warte mal, Musik wollten wir jetzt nicht. 23 Uhr haben wir's. Hier ist Chaosradio auf Fritz, das heißt, es gibt auch Nerd News, die sind heute zusammengestellt worden von Mo und werden gelesen von Merlin.
Chacey Manning ist frei. In der letzten Woche wurde Chacey Manning nach sieben Jahren aus der Haft entlassen. Sie war zu einer 35-jährigen Haftstrafe verurteilt worden, nachdem sie militärische Dokumente weitergegeben hatte. Die schwerste Verfehlung des US-amerikanischen Militärs dokumentierten. Der ehemalige US-Präsident Obama hatte die Strafe reduziert mit der Begründung, dass das Strafmaß nicht verhältnismäßig gewesen sei. Interne Regeln für Inhaltslöschung bei Facebook befreit. Der Guardian hat Lernmaterial veröffentlicht, anhand dessen die Mitarbeiter von Facebook Inhalte überprüfen und gegebenenfalls löschen sollen. Die Dokumente gewähren Einblicke in die internen Regeln des US-Konzerns, wie mit Inhalten umgegangen werden soll, die gegen die Nutzungsbedingungen verstoßen könnten. Die intransparenten Nutzungsbedingungen geraten immer wieder in den Fokus der Öffentlichkeit, wenn bestimmte Inhalte wie Bilder entfernt oder Inhalte mit Hate Speech nicht gelöscht werden. Facebook wird regelmäßig vorgeworfen, seine Verantwortung nicht wahrzusehen, sodass es mittlerweile immer wieder politische Vorstöße gibt, um das soziale Netzwerk in seine Schranken zu weisen. Premierminister May will Internet in Großbritannien vollständig staatlich regulieren. Sollte Mays konservative Partei die Wahlen im Juni gewinnen, will sie das Internet deutlich stärker als bisher regulieren. Dem Wahlprogramm der Partei zufolge sollen Internetfirmen gesetzlich dazu verpflichtet werden, die Nutzer weder mit Absicht, noch unabsichtlich zu Hassreden, Pornografie oder anderen schädlichen Inhalten zu führen. Diese Regelungen sollen dem Schutz der Minderjährigen dienen. Das soll sowohl für soziale Medien, als auch für Webseiten und Applikationen gelten.
Die NerdNews im Chaosradio auf Fritz. Danke, Merlin.
Radio hat einen Namen.
Willkommen zurück. Hier ist der Blue Moon auf Ritz heute mit dem Chaos Radio. Ich bin Konrad Spremberg und drei Menschen vom Chaos Computer Club sind mit mir im Studio. Alex ist da.
Hallo.
Peter auch. Und Danimo. Hallo. So wir reden über WannaCry heute Abend. Dieser Name ist ja auch geil. I WannaCry haben sich bestimmt einige der Betroffenen gedacht, deren Rechner von diesem Trojaner infiziert worden sind, die dann ihre gesamten Daten verschlüsselt bekommen haben und dazu aufgerufen wurden, Geld in Bitcoin zu bezahlen, um die Daten wieder frei zu bekommen. Ich hab gerade mal gesehen, es gibt einen Twitter-Account, könnt ihr nachgucken, der heißt actual ransom, actual unterstrich ransom auf Twitter. Da wird immer getwittert, wenn jemand bezahlt hat für diesen WannaCry Trojaner. Wir haben schon kurz erklärt, es gibt dieses System, das heißt Blockchain, du siehst alles, was passiert in dem System, du siehst in diesem Bitcoinsystem, welche Zahlungen, wohin, an welches Bitcoins Portemonnaie fließen. Kannst deswegen auch sehr genau sehen, was diese Erpresser schon eingenommen haben mit ihrem Trojaner. Und hier zum Beispiel kann man sehen, gerade vor sechs Stunden hat zuletzt ein Mensch für WannaCry bezahlt. Und zwar ist die Summe jetzt gerade bei, nee, es waren 34 US-Dollar. Und kann das sein, das passt doch nicht. Aber steht hier.
136.000.
Vielleicht in einem Land, wo die Summe dann etwas geringer ist.
Das war's, das hat er erzählt. Stimmt, es gibt ja Länder, wo man viel, viel weniger bezahlen muss, weil die Länder an sich ärmer sind. Okay, also da hat offensichtlich jemand bezahlt in einem Land, wo die Menschen in Dollar umgerechnet weniger Geld haben. Und deswegen musste er nur in Anführungszeichen 34 Dollar und 11 bezahlen. Kann man alles nachvollziehen. Es gibt hier automatisiert haufenweise Tweets. Vor acht Stunden zum Beispiel kam ein ganzer Haufen rein. Ist auf jeden Fall interessant zu sehen, um ja rauszubekommen, wie viele Menschen den Erpressern schon gefolgt sind sozusagen. Wir haben so die Grundlagen alle schon ganz gut besprochen, glaube ich. Was WannaCry ist, was so ein Pressungs-Trojaner ist und wie das Ganze funktioniert hat, könnt ihr nachhören nach der Sendung im Podcast auf fritz.de. Jetzt würde ich gerne einmal noch zusammenfassen, warum haben die das gemacht? Ging es nur ums Geldverdienen oder hatten die auch noch andere Gründe das zu tun, Leute vielleicht auszuspionieren, keine Ahnung?
Also in diesem Fall ist das tatsächlich ein bisschen merkwürdig, weil eben, wie schon vorhin erwähnt, die Zahlungen, die da jetzt eingehen, doch eher gering sind. Aber es ist bisher nicht nachgewiesen oder gezeigt, dass dieser Crypto-Trojaner irgendetwas anderes tut, als das, was im Prinzip draufsteht, also die Dateien zu verschlüsseln. Das heißt, man kann tatsächlich davon ausgehen, dass es in dem Fall irgendwie ums Geld geht.
Okay, also wahrscheinlich keine Menschen, die irgendwas wissen wollen über mich, wenn sie mich angreifen?
Eher unwahrscheinlich.
Okay, jetzt lass uns mal drüber sprechen, was ich tun kann, damit ich nicht Opfer werde von sowas. Ihr habt schon gesagt, es geht da viel ums Updates einspielen. Jetzt könnte ich ja denken, ich hab doch einen Virenscanner. Ist doch kein Problem.
Ja, also jetzt inzwischen haben natürlich die Vendoren dann auch, also die ganzen Firmen, die eben jetzt Virenscanner herstellen, haben jetzt natürlich auch schon vernünftige Signaturen, also die passenden Merkmale im Prinzip von diesem Krypto-Locker, um den halt zu finden und dann eben auch eine Infektion zu verhindern. Aber natürlich so ganz in der frühen Phase, wo das erst anläuft, da gibt es dann immer so eine gewisse Zeit, die es halt dauert, bis dann tatsächlich die Signaturen da sind, bis dann der Virenscanner da auch schützt. Und jetzt gerade so Industriesysteme haben jetzt vielleicht auch gar keinen Virenscanner, weil das sind dann vielleicht irgendwelche Echtzeitsysteme, wo das dann eher nicht geht. Oder die sind halt einfach jetzt gar nicht so als Computer wahrgenommen, sondern es ist halt diese Box, die irgendwo neben der Fräse steht und wo mein Bildschirm dran ist, wo ich halt drauf klicke, um meine Fräspunkte zu setzen. Das heißt jetzt in diesem Fall ist das jetzt nicht verwunderlich, dass da vielleicht auch so später noch Infektionen passieren.
Die Virenscanner, die können nur reagieren, die funktionieren nicht proaktiv.
Das heißt die NSA zum Beispiel hatte zwar alles, was die Virenscanner-Hersteller hätten haben müssen, um sich darauf vorzubereiten.
Wie auch Microsoft.
Wie auch Microsoft. Aber die Virenscanner-Hersteller sind nicht informiert worden, konnten also erst reagieren, als der Virus schon unterwegs war.
Tatsächlich hatten sogar die Virenscanner-Hersteller in dem Fall schon die Möglichkeiten, Teile von der Malware hier zu erkennen. Dadurch, dass dieser Exploit, der von NSA entwickelt wurde, auch schon vorher öffentlich war, gab es im Prinzip schon die Möglichkeit, Signaturen zu bauen für diese Art von Angriff gegen ein Zielsystem. Aber? Bedingt dadurch, wie Virenscanner funktionieren, kann das teilweise schwierig zu implementieren sein, schwierig zu finden sein. Dieser Exploit ist dann auch relativ speziell dadurch, dass es in den Betriebssystemen Kern geht. Man spricht von User-Land jetzt nicht in dem Bereich, wo normale Applikationen wie mein Word laufen, sondern tatsächlich in dem Bereich, wo dann die Grundfunktionalitäten von meinem Betriebssystem sind.
In Windows innen drin?
Genau, ganz tief unten drin.
Jetzt habt ihr auch schon mehrmals gesagt, dass eines der wichtigsten Themen, über die wir unter dem Stichpunkt vorbeugen reden müssen, Updates sind. Irgendwelche Patches, die für mein System rausgegeben werden oder Updates für einzelne Softwareprogramme. Jetzt mache ich es meistens so. Ich bekomme einen Pop-up und da steht drin, hey, es gibt eine neue Version, cool, installiere die mal. Dann drücke ich drauf und dann habe ich die installiert. Gibt es Sachen, die ich trotzdem falsch machen kann, wenn ich so vorgehe, in dem mich schützen wollen vor so einem Virus?
Ja, Quellen. Wo kommt diese Anfrage her oder diese Meldung her? Ist die wirklich von dem Softwarehersteller oder bist du gerade auf einer Webseite, wo vielleicht jemand Werbung zeigt, die so aussieht, als wäre das ein Update-Angebot? Und wenn du draufklickst, passiert was ganz anderes. Vielleicht kriegst du dann den Trojaner sogar.
Dein Mikrofon muss an.
Genau. Und da ist natürlich die Möglichkeit, die du hast, im Zweifelsfall alle Browser alles zu machen, was irgendwie Webseiten anzeigt. Und dann sich mal dieses Fenster genau angucken. Normalerweise, wenn man die Browser wirklich geschlossen hat und wenn man sich sicher ist, dass der Browser an sich gar nicht mehr läuft und dieses Fenster immer noch sichtbar ist, dann kann man sich normalerweise angucken, was sind das für Updates und so weiter und so fort. Da kann man sich dann schon relativ sicher sein, weil normalerweise diese Update-Warnungen, die als Werbung ausgespielt werden, die sind darauf getrimmt und die sind auch visuell so gestaltet, dass man auf jeden Fall sofort draufklickt.
Ja, ich kenn das, ne? Da kommt dann gerne mal unten rechts so ein Kasten hochgefahren. Hey, Ihre Anti-Virus-Software muss ganz dringend geupdatet werden. Drücken Sie hier drauf. Blink, blink.
Auf gar keinen Fall unter Druck setzen lassen.
Also drück jetzt. Tu es.
Genau.
Also alles, was blinkt, ist generell erst mal schlecht.
Das finde ich super. Lass uns mal kurz so eine einfache Update-Routine entwickeln. Also ich möchte mich gegen WannaCry oder alle möglichen anderen Viren schützen. Ich möchte das tun, indem ich alle Updates gut fahre. So, wir haben uns schon gelernt. Ich achte darauf, dass ich, wenn irgendein Pop-Up kommt, was mir sagt, du brauchst ein Update, dass ich checke, kann das wirklich das echte Pop-Up von dieser Software sein? Dazu kann ich alle Browser schließen, um das gegenzuchecken. Und dann noch mal schauen, sieht das authentisch aus, könnte das passen. Und wenn ich da sage, ja, das sieht mir vertrauenswürdig aus, dann fahre ich das Update. Worauf muss ich noch achten?
Ist es das?
Geht es nur noch darum, regelmäßig Updates zu machen?
Es gibt natürlich immer noch Software, die sich nicht von selber updatet. Das heißt Software, die man benutzt, die man regelmäßig benutzt, oder Software, die Dienst auch anbietet vor allen Dingen. Das ist jetzt bei Enternwendern im Normalfall nicht so, aber es gibt gerade irgendwelche Spezialsoftware, wo man sagt, hier, mach das mal, und mach dann mal irgendwie eine Portweiterleitung auf dem Router. Das kriegt man immer mal wieder so zu hören. Und dann kannst du ganz schnell irgendwelche Dienste anbieten. Und immer, wenn man das hört, das sind immer die Programme, mit denen man im Zweifelsfall hinterher Ärger haben kann, wenn die nicht auch automatisch regelmäßig upgedatet werden.
Stichwort Portweiterleitung. Da sollte man misstrauisch werden.
Es gibt ja auch Software, die man kauft, wo Updates vielleicht gar nicht Teil von dem Produkt oder von dem Angebot sind. Da auch aufpassen. Das ist schon ein wichtiger Wert, dass die Software geupdatet werden kann, dass man Updates für eine gewisse Zeit mitbekommt, wenn man eine Software kauft.
Wie war es dann jetzt bei WannaCry? Ihr habt schon gesagt, da war der Kern des Windows-Betriebssystems quasi die Stelle mit dem Loch. Das bedeutet, in dem Fall haben Leute wahrscheinlich ignoriert, dass Windows gesagt hat, hallo, du kannst mich updaten.
Genau, und Windows hat das tatsächlich in der lautesten möglichen Version gesagt. Also an so Windows-Update-Benachrichtigungen, da stehen dann immer so Warnlevel dran im Wesentlichen. Wie schlimm brennt es jetzt gerade? Und in dem Fall hat Microsoft sinnbildlich dran geschrieben, helllodernd und mit Wasser können wir jetzt auch nicht mehr löschen. Da geht nur noch Sand. Das ist tatsächlich in dem Fall so, dass jetzt alle Administratoren und alle Leute, die irgendwie zuständig sind für jetzt Updates in Netzwerken, die haben das mitbekommen. Also da gab es eigentlich keine Möglichkeit, das zu übersehen. Das wurde eben von Microsoft selber als Warmable bezeichnet. Das heißt, es ist halt eine Lücke, die wirklich dazu geeignet ist, dass sich unerwünschte Software selbstständig unter Ausnutzung dieser Lücke im Netzwerk fortbewegt.
Und geschützt werden... Also warte mal, jeder hätte sich schützen können, indem er da auf Update rechtzeitig geklickt hätte.
Genau, ja nun ist es in jetzt vier Netzwerken nicht unbedingt so, dass man direkt die Updates von dem Windows-Update-Server holt. Sondern da gibt es dann in der Regel so einen Zwischenpunkt noch, wo dann eben die Updates gesammelt werden und dann werden die eben einzeln freigegeben.
Nachdem die getestet worden sind.
Also so eine firmeninterne Zwischenschleife noch quasi.
Qualitätssicherung, ja.
Und die hat dann vielleicht teilweise zu lange gedauert?
Genau, da ist es jetzt natürlich je nach Konstrukt so, dass man dafür dann vielleicht irgendeinen Dienstleister hat oder eben einfach sehr langsame Prozesse, die dann unter Umständen einfach dazu geführt haben, dass das einfach viel zu lange gedauert hat und selbst so ein kritisches Update eben nicht notfallmäßig außer der Reihe eingespielt wurde.
Das bedeutet, jetzt gerade wäre für solche Firmen zum Beispiel zu tun, dass die ihre Strukturen überarbeiten und dafür sorgen, dass Updates schneller auf den Rechnern landen?
Genau.
Okay, was wäre noch eine Konsequenz? Also jetzt habe ich mitbekommen, ich bin nicht betroffen, aber es ist überall passiert.
Möglichst Systeme isolieren, dass die nicht beliebig im Internet verfügbar sind, dass die auch nicht beliebig miteinander kommunizieren können. Wenn man in einer Firma vielleicht Produktion und Vertrieb hat, macht es Sinn, da zwei verschiedene Netzwerke zu haben, sodass ein Problem in dem anderen Bereich sich nicht beliebig verbreiten kann.
So könnte man zumindest verhindern, dass gleich die gesamte Firma befallen ist, sondern vielleicht die Zahl der Rechner halbieren oder so. Aber damit könnte man nicht verhindern, dass es passiert.
An sich nicht, nur wenn man dann sowohl Produktion als auch Vertrieb aus dem Internet komplett fernhält oder weglässt, ist Vertrieb natürlich schwierig.
Aber das ist nicht ein Problem, was ich als Privatanwender habe, oder es besteht eine Chance, dass mein Rechner jetzt gerade im Internet ist, erreichbar ist über eine öffentliche IP.
Je nach Portweiterleitung.
Es gibt halt auch Router, die machen sogenanntes UPNP, Universal Plug and Play. Und er kann ein Programm anmelden. Ich hätte gerne eine Portweiterleitung. Der Router sagt, du wirst schon wissen, was du tust, die hasse. Und das ist also auch ein Tipp, UPNP abschalten.
Kommt auch auf die Liste.
Kommt auch auf die Liste. Bitte?
Also nicht nur eure Rechner könnten problematisch sein, vor allem könnte auch euer Router Probleme machen. Alles klar.
Genau, und die größte Problematik ist etwas, was sich die Betriebssystemhersteller gerade selber reinholen. Sowohl Microsoft als auch Apple gehen ja jetzt gerade die Schiene, für das Betriebssystem gern Geld mehr zu verlangen, weil sie andere Einkommensquellen haben. Bei Microsoft sind das die Cloud-Dienste, bei Apple ist das der Store. Und auch Microsoft würde gerne in Richtung eines Stores gehen, wo sie quasi, Moment, genau, ja eigentlich ist es gut. Eigentlich ist es gut, denkt man. Und dann ist aber das Problem, sie verwandeln ihre Betriebssysteme in sich ewig verändernde Dinge. Das heißt, bei Updates kriegst du nicht nur Sicherheitsupdates, sondern auf einmal sieht alles ganz anders aus.
Deine Lieblingsfunktion ist nicht mehr da.
Oder ist jetzt woanders. Und das ist das große Problem, damit minderst du signifikant die Akzeptanz von Updates, weil die Leute dann sagen, was hilft mir das denn, dass ich jetzt sicher bin, wenn ich nicht mehr arbeiten kann, weil ich mich jetzt erstmal umgewöhnen muss.
Noch schlimmer, deine alte Dokumente kannst du gar nicht mehr öffnen.
Unter Umständen. Oft ist es halt auch wirklich so ein bisschen so, dass man die Anwender so ein bisschen in Akzeptanz schulen muss und ihnen dann halt auch eine Handreichung geben muss. Das würde ich mir ehrlich gesagt auch von den Betriebssystemherstellern noch ein bisschen mehr wünschen, dass sie da eher einen kooperativen Weg gehen, als einen Weg, wo sie sagen, wir geben hier per order of the move die vor, wie die Dinge jetzt sind. Und du hast sie zu fressen und du hast im Idealerweise auch selber rauszufinden, wie das jetzt funktioniert. Und man muss einfach einen Weg finden, wenn man Security Updates und normale Updates unbedingt vermischen will, was halt gerne getan wird. Gerade für den Privatanwender ist das ja überhaupt nicht ersichtlich. Man muss Wege schaffen, dass diese Akzeptanz steigt. Und das passiert eben gerade nicht, weil einfach das Ziel gerade ist, das Betriebssystem weiter zu entwickeln mit den Updates. Und dann sagen, die einzige Möglichkeit ist halt, die mit den Security Updates zu verreichen, weil sonst gibt es überhaupt keine Motivation für den Endanwender.
Also die Hersteller hoffen, dass die Endanwender sich denken, ey ich brauch Sicherheits Updates, ich hol mir halt die blöden neuen Funktionen. Und manche Anwender denken sich, geh du mir weg mit deinen neuen Funktionen, da hol ich mir auch kein Sicherheits Update.
Genau.
Okay, und eine Konsequenz könnte zum Beispiel sein, dass die Hersteller ihre Updates einfach getrennt ausspielen. Aber das tun sie nicht, weil sie dann weniger tolle neue Funktionen anbringen können.
Genau, also letztendlich läuft das nicht anders, als wirklich einen vernünftigen Dialog hinzukriegen. Und das sehe ich einfach nicht.
Und dann gibt es ja noch das Problem, im Fall von Windows XP zum Beispiel ist das so, dass ein System noch überall im Gebrauch ist, aber gar nicht mehr regulär vom Hersteller gepatcht wird. Stimmt's?
Richtig, seit einigen Jahren schon nicht mehr.
Wobei auch da gibt es wieder Gleiche und Gleichere. Nämlich die Leute, die sich einen erweiterten Support-Vertrag bei Microsoft geklickt haben, für wirklich, wirklich viel Geld, die haben diesen Patch tatsächlich auch von Windows XP bekommen. Und der Rest hat es erst dann bekommen, in dem Moment, wo klar war, wie schlimm die Lücke ist und Microsoft sich dem nicht erwähnen konnte. Allerdings, was soll Microsoft tun? Irgendwann müssen sie alte Betriebssysteme abkündigen. Und da würde ich auch tatsächlich nicht mal die Schuld bei Microsoft sehen, sondern da würde ich wirklich die Hersteller der Systeme in der Verantwortung sehen, dass sie halt sagen, so ab der und der Zeit können wir dafür nicht mehr die Sicherheit gewährleisten. Dann müsst ihr die Systeme so und so isolieren vom Rest des Netzes.
Also zum Beispiel, wir haben ja dieses Fabrikbeispiel, da ist ein Roboter, der Autos herstellt und der kann halt leider nur mit XP arbeiten. Und die Fabrik will keinen neuen Roboter anschaffen. Behält deswegen das XP-System bei sich. Da müsste man sagen, das ist verboten, den noch im Netz zu haben.
Zum Beispiel.
Und ansonsten für alle anderen, die nicht irgendwelche Roboter betreiben, also ich meine, XP benutzen ja noch meine Oma zum Beispiel und viele andere Menschen. Die Leute sind einfach, ich sag mal, nicht so schlau, wenn sie XP behalten.
Wie ist denen schlecht da? Es kümmert sich keiner.
Wobei bei XP gibt es auch mittlerweile Pop-Ups, die davor waren, die zumindest ganz klar machen, es ist gefährlich. Da ist halt das Problem, dass die Leute das nicht unbedingt einschätzen können, was jetzt gefährlich heißt. Und da ist halt im Prinzip, das ist das Einzige, was den Leuten bleibt, ist irgendwie auf den House Nerd vertrauen und den House Nerd konsultieren. Und wer keinen House Nerd hat, ist halt völlig verloren.
Die Lösung ist halt einfach XP abschaffen zu Hause, Punkt.
Wichtig, das ist das, was der Haus Nerd hoffentlich sagen würde.
Leider, das freut Microsoft natürlich, weil so dürfen die dann mehr Betriebssysteme verkaufen. Aber tatsächlich sollte man nicht zu alte Software verwenden. Weil das war jetzt eine gravierende Sicherheitslücke oder ein großer Fehler in Windows. Das wird nicht der einzige sein. Es gibt ganz viele von denen, die wir gar nicht kennen. Und es wird die ganze Zeit geforscht, um weitere Lücken zu finden. Es gibt dafür auch einen Markt, leider.
Das heißt, wenn Microsoft bei euch anklopft und sagt, hol dir doch mal ein neues System. Die machen das natürlich auch, weil sie dir Sachen verkaufen wollen. Aber das hat auch einen guten Grund.
Auf jeden Fall.
Man kann ja den Hausnörtern doch auch noch mal fragen, ob der vielleicht schon mal von diesem Linux was gehört hat.
Na, jetzt wird es aber sehr nerdy. Also meine Oma und Linux, es wird nüscht mehr, kann ich dir sagen. Ähm, jetzt ist das passiert. Und es sind haufenweise Leute betroffen gewesen oder haben diese Meldung angezeigt bekommen. Diejenigen, die sich halbwegs zurücklehnen konnten, waren die mit vernünftigen Updates, Backups meine ich.
Mit vernünftigen Backups. Das ist tatsächlich etwas, was ich unter Windows so ein bisschen erschreckend finde, weil man sich da tatsächlich selber kümmern muss.
Ja, ich liebe es als Mac-Nutzer, dass man da einfach nichts tun muss für.
Genau. Time Machine hat auch einen sehr vernünftigen Ansatz. Nämlich diese Backups, die quasi so einem Logarithmus folgen. Nämlich, wenn du vom jetzigen Datum, machen sie es zum Beispiel, da werden die Backups behalten, so wie sie gemacht werden. Was weiß ich, wenn du eingestellt hast jede Stunde im Extremfall, dann kriegst du tatsächlich jede Stunde, kannst du zurück. Und je weiter es in die Vergangenheit geht, dann werden nur noch täglich oder wöchentlich Backups behalten. Und die Theorie dahinter ist natürlich, wenn dir irgendetwas kaputt geht, dann kann dir das zu jeder beliebigen Zeit passieren. Aber wenn du wirklich in die Vergangenheit greifen musst, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es wichtig ist, zu welcher Sekunde oder zu welcher Minute das passiert ist, eigentlich minimal und da ist einfach nur wichtig, dass du irgendeinen Datenstand hast. Und ob der jetzt zwei Minuten älter ist oder nicht, ist eigentlich völlig egal dabei. Und das ist das, was Time Machine macht, das ist das, was auch andere Backups machen. Bei Windows muss man die allerdings... Windows hat auch so ein rudimentäres Tool, aber das ist tatsächlich...
Also für Windows 7 wurde das jetzt nochmal so ein bisschen, oder Windows 10 glaube ich, ein bisschen renoviert. Das heißt dann glaube ich File History. Und das muss man halt manuell einschalten. Ich bin mir aber ehrlich gesagt gar nicht sicher, ob das so in der Basisversion, die wahrscheinlich die meisten Anwender zu Hause haben, überhaupt schon drin ist.
Ist das überhaupt wirklich ein Backup-Tool, oder ist das nicht nur das Dateisystem, das sich Dinge merkt? Das ist ja dann kein richtiges Backup-Tool.
Das ist ein Versionierungs- und Backup-Tool.
Aber festhalten, Mac-Nutzer können sich vergleichsweise einfach zurücklehnen. Aber wenn ich jetzt Windows habe, wie sieht denn eine gute Backup-Strategie für mich aus, um mich im Fall, ich werde befallen, meine Daten sind weg, nochmal retten zu können?
Externe Datenträger, externe Festplatte, USB-Sticks und einfach deine Dateien mehrmals kopieren.
Ja, aber ist ja ätzend, wenn ich jedes Mal alle meine Daten von Hand sichere. Es gibt ja mit Sicherheit auch für Windows gute Update-Lösungen Software-technisch, oder?
Backup-Lösungen.
Ich sage ganz ehrlich, Backup-Lösungen meine ich ja.
Genau, vielleicht kann jemand sich melden, der sowas kennt.
Wir haben die Kommentare in unserem Blog offen und da kommen immer sehr viele hilfreiche Hinweise. Wir selber, also ich wüsste jetzt tatsächlich unter Windows tatsächlich vergleichsweise nicht. Wie gesagt, die Systeme, die ich administriere, sind halt größere Systeme. Da haben die Systeme einfach keinen Wert, sondern da gibt es halt einen zentralen Datalserver. Der wird halt entsprechend mit einer Software, die mitgeliefert wird, die auch dann Linux basiert ist, entsprechend gebackuped. Das heißt, wenn mir jemand einen Endcomputer verschlüsselt, dann ist mir das tatsächlich vollkommen egal.
Okay, also guckt ins CCC-Blog, wenn ihr keine vernünftige Software habt. Da kommen hoffentlich gerade schon Vorschläge.
Chaosradio.ccc.de dann.
Genau. Und... Ist es wirklich... Also, ihr klingt gerade, als wäre es einfach schwierig, für Windows was zu finden. Ich stelle mir vor, es muss doch irgendeinen Hersteller geben.
Es gibt Backup-Lösungen für Windows, ganz sicher. Ich kann nur keine Empfehlung machen.
Okay, verstehe.
Genau. Also, ich kann vielleicht doch eine Empfehlung machen. Das ist ein Open-Source-Tool, Restick heißt das. Das ist allerdings dann eher für Leute, die ohnehin mehr auf der Kommandozeile unterwegs sind und das auch selber compiled bekommen. Aber das kann man sich sonst mal anschauen. Das ist github.com.
Nicht für Oma.
Slash Restick.
Aber wenn ihr mit Kommandozeile umgehen könnt, ihr Nerds da draußen, dann holt euch das.
Also, unsere Hörer sind da doch recht gut auf Zack.
Ja, die Hörer, die den Podcast hören, aber die Menschen, die jetzt gerade Fritz hören, die wollen wir auch mitnehmen. Ihr geht bitte auf chaosradio.ccc.de und findet da hoffentlich gleich ganz viele tolle Empfehlungen für euer System zu Hause, die super einfach zu bedienen sind und trotzdem alles tun, was eine gute Backup-Lösung tun sollte. Was sollte ich noch tun? Backups, Updates fahren, gibt es noch andere Vorbeugungsmaßnahmen, die wichtig sind?
Im Zweifelsfall alles abschalten, was man nicht wirklich braucht an Diensten. Das ist bei Windows tatsächlich in diesem Fall etwas schwierig, weil niemand standardmäßig auf die Idee kommt, dieses Dateiteilen, dieses System von Dateien, eine mögliche sogenannte SMB abzuschalten. Das macht einfach niemand.
Für Freigaben und Druckerteilen.
Aber es gibt immerhin da die Windows-Firewall. Eigentlich moderne Windows-Systeme fragen dich auch, in welcher Umgebung bist du eigentlich gerade unterwegs? Bist du zu Hause? Bist du in der Firma? Und das ist tatsächlich etwas, wo Microsoft eigentlich nachgedacht hat. Weil entsprechend, was man jetzt sagt, wird die Umgebung halt als mehr oder weniger vertrauenswürdig eingestuft. Das ist tatsächlich etwas, was sie an den Anwender aber nicht kommunizieren. Was manchmal passiert ist, dass Leute sich keine Vorstellung machen. Was ist jetzt der Unterschied zwischen, ob ich jetzt zu Hause oder in der Firma bin?
Ich kann das auch nicht sagen. Ich meine, ich weiß, wie eine Firewall funktioniert und was sie macht oder machen sollte. Aber ich weiß nicht, welche Entscheidung in Microsoft bei diesen zwei Wahlmöglichkeiten getroffen hat. Ich weiß also nicht, was ich...
Aber du sagst dann, Nemo, es ist schon sinnvoll da, wirklich das anzuklicken, wo ich gerade bin.
Genau. Und im Zweifelsfall sich auch mal da einzulesen. Auch Microsoft hat da durchaus Dokumentation. Wer verstehen will, welche Dienste und welche Funktionalität in welchen dieser Szenarien dann eingeschränkt wird?
Leider kommt Windows mit viel zu vielen Diensten eingeschaltet. Für meinen Geschmack wenigstens.
Und es geht also darum, wie ihr gerade sagtet, einfach mal Systemsteuerung anklicken, vieles durchgehen, gucken, wo man Schalter hat an aus. Und bei Sachen, die man nicht braucht, auf Ausstellen, das kann schon die Sicherheit erhöhen.
Das erhöht auf jeden Fall die Sicherheit, weil weniger in dem System passiert. Ja, ausgeführt wird.
Das ist der einzige Nachteil natürlich. Dann fallen natürlich gewisse Erwartungen wieder hinten runter. Dass mein Netzwerkdrucker automatisch erkannt wird, in dem Moment, wo ich keinen Dienst laufen habe, wo sich ein Drucker melden kann oder sonst irgendetwas. Normalerweise ist es andersrum, aber um ein Beispiel zu konstruieren, dann kann es halt passieren. Oder auch diese Scanning-Dienste werden ausgestellt, weil sich jemand als Drucker ausgeben könnte und dann Unfug machen könnte. Also es gibt halt verschiedene Abstufungen. Fakt oder Punkt ist, in dem Moment gehe ich ein Risiko ein und wenn ich das Risiko abschalte, dann bezahle ich mit Komfortverlust. Ich finde halt den Drucker nicht mehr automatisch. Ich muss ihn manuell einrichten und jeder da draußen wird mir recht geben, es gibt nichts beschissenes als Drucker einzurichten. Und jeder Hersteller lässt sich da auch was eigenes gerne einfallen. Und wenn dann die Betriebssystemautomatik, die mittlerweile bei einigen Betriebssystemen sogar ganz gut funktioniert, um Drucker automatisch zu finden, wenn das dann abgeschaltet werden muss, dann jammern die Anwender wieder.
Man kann das ja einschalten oder eingeschaltet lassen, den Drucker installieren und danach ausschalten. Drucker installieren macht man nun nicht jeden Tag. Und ja, das ist mehr Aufwand auf jeden Fall.
Aber es lohnt sich.
Es ist schlimmer, als Daten zu verlieren.
Also Backups regelmäßig machen, Updates schnell fahren und unnötige Dienste auf dem System ausschalten, sind auf jeden Fall drei sehr wertvolle Tipps, um sich zu schützen gegen Angriffe von zum Beispiel WannaCry, aber auch allen möglichen anderen Trojanern, die es auf euch oder anderen Viren, die es auf eure Systeme abgesehen haben könnten. Was zu tun ist, wenn ihr doch betroffen seid und was zu tun ist in Sachen Politik und so weiter, darüber sprechen wir in der letzten halben Stunde vom Chaosradio gleich nach den Fritz Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Das Helene Beach ist so etwas wie die Perle unter den Festivals. Vier Tage Sommer, Sonne, Strand und Meer. Also für Sommer und Sonne können wir nicht garantieren, aber für Meer. Mit Haftbefehl, S-Type 83 und der Antilopen Gang. Mit Schmutzky, Pretty Pink und den Awesons. Und das sind längst noch nicht alle. Das Helene Beach Festival. Donnerstag 27. Abends, Sonntag 30. Am Helene See bei Frankfurt Oder. Präsentiert von die Perle unter die Radios.
23 Uhr, 32.
Der Fall des in der Türkei inhaftierten Journalisten Yücel beschäftigt bald den Europäischen Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte. Das berichtet die Welt, für die Yücel als Korrespondent tätig ist. Das Gericht in Straßburg habe die Beschwerde Yüces gegen seine Untersuchungshaft demnach angenommen und wolle sie zügig behandeln. Yücel sitzt seit Ende Februar in der Türkeien-Untersuchungshaft. Ihm werden Terrorpropaganda und Volksverhetzung vorgeworfen. Die europäischen NATO-Staaten sollen mehr Geld für die Verteidigung ausgeben. Das hat US-Präsident Trump zum Auftakt des NATO-Gipfels in Brüssel gesagt. Die europäischen Staaten des Verteidigungsbundes hatten 2014 vereinbart, zwei Prozent ihrer Wirtschaftsleistung für die Verteidigung auszugeben. Die meisten Staaten geben bisher aber weniger aus. Neben den USA erfüllen nur Griechenland, Estland, Großbritannien und Polen die Vorgabe. Die Menschen sollen sich gegen Fremdenhass und Nationalismus einsetzen. Das hat der ehemalige US-Präsident Obama beim Evangelischen Kirchentag in Berlin gesagt. Bei einer Diskussionsrunde am Brandenburger Tor, an der auch Bundeskanzlerin Merkel teilnahm, sagte er, man müsse sich hinter demokratische Werte stellen und gegen die eintreten, die diese Werte zurückdringen wollten. Merkel sagte, die deutsche Asylpolitik müsse sich auf die Menschen in der Welt konzentrieren, die dringend Hilfe brauchen. In der Relegation für die erste Fußball-Bundesliga hat Wolfsburg das Hinspiel gegen Braunschweig gewonnen. Die Partie endete 1 zu 0. Das Rückspiel findet am Montag in Braunschweig statt. Dann entscheidet sich, wer in der nächsten Saison in der ersten Liga spielt. Das Wetter Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Berlin-Zehlendorf 14 Grad, Atlershof 15 Grad, Cottbus 10 Grad, Lindenberg und Neuropin 12 Grad, Ludwigsfelde 13 Grad. Auch in der Nacht bleibt es trocken und klar, das Thermometer sinkt bis auf 7 Grad. Der Freitag startet bewirkt, es bleibt aber meist trocken. Im Laufe des Tages kommt dann auch die Sonne raus, bei Höchstwerten von 23 Grad in Berlin und 24 Grad in Brandenburg. Stadtverkehr Berlin. In Mitte ist die Brunnenstraße in Höhe Bernauer Straße in beiden Richtungen nach einem Unfall im Kreuzungsbereich gesperrt. In Tiergarten ist die Straße des 17. Juni zwischen Großem Stern und Ebertstraße bis zum 11. Juni gesperrt. Gesperrt sind auch die Ebert- und die Jetser Gravienstraße. Und wegen der Kirchentagsabendkonzerte gibt es am Freitag und Sonnenabend jeweils ab 15 Uhr bis metern Nacht zusätzliche Sperrungen rund um das Brandenburger Tor. Ein unterwegs, eine gute Fahrt.
Und wenn ihr gute Tipps in Sachen Mode, Filme, neue Platten, Bücher oder Games wollt, dann klickt doch mal fritz.de slash Tipps.
Ja Seid gegrüßt, hier ist das Chaos Radio im Blue Moon auf Fritz. Der Chaos Computer Club ist teilweise zu Gast im Fritz Studio. Danni muss hier.
Hallo.
Peter. Ach so, willst du ein Mikro haben, Peter?
Ja.
Hier, guck mal. Und Alex, hey, hast auch ein rotes Licht jetzt. So, wir reden über WannaCry heute, diesen Trojaner, der vor knapp zwei Wochen auf der ganzen Welt befallen hat. Wir haben gerade darüber gesprochen, was man tun kann, um sich zu schützen vor sowas, um vorzubeugen solchen Infektionen. Wir müssen jetzt kurz was noch nachreichen. Also wir haben gerade gesagt, es kann hilfreich sein, wenn ihr unnötige Dienste ausschaltet, die euer Computer macht. Bitte tut das nicht wahllos. Genau.
Also da gehört jetzt nicht der Windows-Update-Dienst zu und auch nicht der Java-Update-Dienst, insofern man dann so etwas hat.
Und die Firewall darf auch gerne bleiben.
Okay, also es gibt schon ein paar Sachen. Ihr soll euch vielleicht Gedanken machen, bevor ihr Sachen ausschaltet, noch mal überlegen, ist das vielleicht sogar wichtig, um mich zu schützen? Also Updates-Prozesse von Windows, von Java, von anderen Software vielleicht sowieso auch. Und Updates sind generell gut.
Genau.
Wichtig.
Wichtig vor allen Dingen.
Okay, die also anlassen und die Firewall bitte auch anlassen.
Generell habe ich im Radio gehört und haben die CCC-Leute gesagt, es ist an sich erstmal keine gute Ausrede, wenn was schief geht. Immer Hirn einschalten.
Ja, das können wir eigentlich über alles schreiben. Immer Hirn einschalten. Wenn es doch passiert ist, wenn ich tatsächlich Opfer geworden bin von WannaCry, gibt es irgendwelche Erste-Hilfe-Sets für mich? Was tue ich? Schreie ich? Renne ich den Kopf gegen die Wand? Schmeiße ich meinen Rechner aus dem Fenster?
Ja, also ich meine...
Oder vielleicht mach ich das zuerst und dann.
Ja, genau, also es hängt jetzt natürlich schwer davon ab, wie gut man jetzt vorbereitet ist. Wenn man jetzt einfach irgendwie seine Backups im Schrank liegen hat, dann würde ich sagen, alles klar, wird wahrscheinlich immer Zeit, das System neu aufzusetzen, dann geht man halt hin und spiel seine Backups wieder ein. Wenn man jetzt einen, ich sag mal hypothetisch Windows 7 hat, das ist jetzt verschlüsselt und ich habe keine Backups, dann hat man nach aktuellem Stand erstmal Pech gehabt. Es gibt zwar die Möglichkeit unter ganz spezifischen Bedingungen bei einem meines Wissens nach nur Windows XP Rechner, den ich jetzt nicht ausgeschaltet hab, seitdem er verschlüsselt wurde, diesen Schlüssel, der eben für die Verschlüsselung verwendet wurde, wieder herzustellen und damit dann die Daten zu entschlüsseln. Aber das wird sehr wahrscheinlich bei den wenigsten Privatpersonen irgendwie so der Fall sein.
Also man müsste den Schlüssel bekommen in irgendeiner Form?
Nee, wenn man jetzt wirklich seinen Rechner nicht ausgeschaltet hat, seitdem verschlüsselt wurde und wenn es eben ein älteres Windows XP ist, da gibt es eben ein Bug, das im Wesentlichen...
Ein guter Bug?
Ja, gut, Ansichtssache. Aber dass halt bestimmter Speicher nicht sauber überschrieben wird oder freigegeben wird. Und da kann dann eben, wenn man Glück hat, noch der Schlüssel drin sein, der eben für das Verschlüsseln der Daten benutzt wurde. Aber das geht nur, wenn man ein altes Windows XP hat und es nicht neu gebootet hat.
Und ist das also eher unwahrscheinlich?
Und ist das ein Programmierfehler in dem Trojaner?
Nee, das ist, glaube ich, auch ein Programmierfehler in der Windows Crypto API. Okay.
Jetzt habe ich einen Faden verloren. Ach so, genau. Also ich bin betroffen und habe ja vielleicht erstmal den Impuls, na gut, bezahle ich halt. Sollte ich das tun?
Lieber nicht. Wenn es irgendwie geht, einfach nicht diese Organisation unterstützen.
Genau. Außerdem hat man ja gehört, der Kundienst ist ja sowieso nicht so gut. Das heißt, es gibt auch gar keine Garantie, dass man seine Daten wiederbekommt.
Sowieso nicht.
Also erstens dem Grund, dass es gerade bei WannaCry bisher noch keinen dokumentierten Fall gibt, wo das was gebracht hat, das Geld zu bezahlen. Und zweitens, weil man mit der Kohle natürlich irgendwie die organisierte Kriminalität unterstützen würde, sollte man das tunlichst lassen. Und wenn man keine Backups hat, halt sich damit zufriedengeben, dass man leider seine Daten verloren hat.
Genau, bevor man bezahlt, vielleicht einmal kurz irgendwie so analog an irgendwie Spenderorgane aus China denken oder so, dann hat man so ungefähr den moralischen Impact.
Okay, aber ich stelle es mir schon schwierig vor, ehrlich gesagt. Also wenn das passiert und ich wirklich richtig wichtige Daten mutmaßlich unwiederbringlich verloren habe, dann, naja, keine Ahnung, versuche ich es vielleicht im Zweifel doch lieber mal mit dem bezahlen.
Das haben ja auch einige versucht.
Aber es ist blöd, macht es nicht.
Lieber Backups machen vorher.
Ja, lieber vorher. Das ist dann zu spät, aber macht es mal lieber vorher.
Der Krypto-Trojaner ist ja auch nicht das einzige Problem. So Festplatten gegen Kaputtrechner werden geklaut. Es gibt viele Gründe, Backups zu machen.
Das ist eigentlich nur sinnvoll, Backups zu machen.
Genau, nicht auf Netzlaufwerke.
Oh, das mache ich zum Beispiel?
Ja, das wäre in dem Fall dann tatsächlich eher schlecht. So moderne Krypto-Trojaner, die gehen halt auch leider dann hin und verschlüsseln alles, was irgendwo auf Netzlaufwerken liegt.
Aber ich hasse es immer, USB an-
und abzustöpseln.
Ja, das tun viele.
Gut, ich würde gerne noch mal kurz die NSA ansprechen, die Rolle der NSA klären. Also ihr habt vorhin gesagt, dieser Geheimdienst war es, der das exploit, den Weg in den Windows-Fehler quasi entdeckt oder gebaut hat und der wurde von denen geleakt. Stimmt's?
Nein, also vorgeblich wurde das eben von der NSA entwickelt, um eben Spionage zu betreiben, um halt in fremde Computersysteme einzubrechen und vielleicht gerade politische Dokumente zu klauen oder irgendwo russische Panzerbaupläne. Und diese, ja eigentlich Waffen kann man sagen, also diese Teile, die zu diesem exploit dazugehören, auch damit man das einfach benutzen kann, damit das eben wirklich für einen Endanwender aus NSA-Sicht nutzbar ist. Da gehört eben noch so ein bisschen Zeug dazu, dass das eben einfach zu nutzen ist. Das ist eben geleakt worden von eben dieser schon erwähnten Shadowbrokers-Gruppe. Und da gibt es verschiedene Theorien, wie die da jetzt drangekommen sind. Eine wahrscheinliche Sache ist schlicht und einfach, dass da irgendein Analyst vielleicht seinen Host, also seinen Computer, wovon aus der dann andere Systeme gaggt hat, nicht aufgeräumt hat. Und eine Gruppe aus einem anderen Land ist da jetzt dann drangekommen und konnte die Daten darunter holen und die ganzen Werkzeuge.
Aber die Grundlage ist, Geheimdienste möchten gerne in Computern von Menschen rumschnüffeln. Deswegen suchen sie Sicherheitslücken. Deswegen entwickeln sie Wege in diese Lücken einzudringen und die Rechner auszuspähen. Und deswegen behalten sie diese Lücken auch für sich und geben sie nicht raus an Viren-Software-Hersteller, Betriebssystemhersteller, Softwarehersteller.
Leider, leider ja. Und das ist eben aus meiner Sicht nicht zielführend für unsere IT-Landschaft.
Das ist vor allem besonders schlimm, wenn man sich überlegt, dass er jetzt auch der amerikanische Geheimdienst Windows-Rechner hat. Also damit dann offensichtlich die Angriffsfähigkeit sozusagen höher priorisiert als jetzt irgendwie die Abwehrfähigkeit, dass man seine eigenen Systeme härtet. Also das ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass es dann geheime Patches für amerikanische Computer gab, die jetzt dagegen gepatcht haben, sondern auch in Anführungszeichen die eigene Regierungssystem und die eigenen Bürger wurden da mitgefährdet, dadurch dass eben jetzt diese Sicherheitslücke nicht gemeldet wurde.
Sämtliche Windows-Nutzer weltweit wurden gefährdet.
Ja und letztendlich, was ich besonders schlimm finde in dem Zusammenhang, wenn man immer, wenn man Politiker da reden hört, dann reden sie von digitalem Erstschlag und weiß ja geier, was nicht alles, was da da teilweise für einen Bullshit kommt. Aber das, was halt wirklich schlimm ist, es werden Analogien gezogen, die so nicht zulässig sind. Also ich kann nicht sagen, ich habe irgendwie eine digitale Bombe und nur ich kann sie einsetzen. Das ist Quatsch. Ich weiß nicht, ob nicht jemand anders genau dieselbe Lücke gefunden hat oder ob nicht jemand mir diese Lücke abspinstig gemacht hat. Und in dem Moment bin ich genauso verwundbar wie jeder andere auch. Das ist nicht so, dass ich irgendwie feststelle, da hat wohl jemand in dem Land, dass wir irgendwie gerade doof finden, da hat es gerade irgendwie gerumst. Das wird wohl so sein, dass sie jetzt auch eine Atombombe haben, sondern man merkt es nicht. Und es kommt der Tag, wie wir das jetzt bei WannaCry gesehen haben, wo das einfach nach hinten losgeht.
Weil die ganze Welt auf einmal betroffen wird.
Genau.
Das ist völlig logisch, aber überlegen wir uns mal, es gäbe das nicht mehr. Geheimdienste würden aufhören, Sicherheitslücken zu horten, um sie für ihre nachrichtendienstlichen Aktivitäten zu benutzen. Dann ginge denen ja ein essenzielles Ding, ihre Arbeit verloren. Und eine Reaktion wäre doch dann, also sie müssten ja eine Alternative finden. Und dann würden wir doch anfangen, darüber zu sprechen, dass Betriebssystemhersteller gezwungen werden, Hintertüren einzubauen für Geheimdienste. Und das wollen wir doch bitte auch nicht, oder?
Ist auf keinen Fall eine gute Lösung.
Ja, und was ist dann die richtige Lösung?
Ich denke mal, eine richtige Lösung in dem Sinne gibt es nicht. Das ist halt jetzt auch ein eher länger zu diskutierendes Thema. Aber vor allem jetzt hinzugehen und Lücken so lange vorrädig zu halten und nicht zu melden, das ist nochmal besonders schlimm. Also das geht gar nicht. Und allgemein zivile Systeme, also ich meine so ein Windows, das ist jetzt nicht, dass irgendwie nur Panzer und Schlachtschiffe auf Windows fahren, dann wäre das jetzt nicht so schlimm, in Anführungszeichen, wenn die sich gegenseitig ihre Panzerhubitzen hacken. Das wäre nochmal eine andere Sache, als wenn ich jetzt hingehe und wirklich so Systeme entwickle, um großflächig zivile Infrastruktur auch zu gefährden. Das geht doch nicht, das ist viel zu gefährlich.
Oder vielleicht nicht absichtlich zivile Systeme gefährdet, aber dass das nebenbei passiert, das ist eigentlich nicht...
Ja, so ist es ja in der Regel wahrscheinlich.
Du sagtest gerade, wir müssen uns irgendwie darüber unterhalten, oder es würde sich dann darüber zwinglich unterhalten, was sonst passiert. Nur was wir jetzt sehen, was zum Beispiel die Bundesregierung jetzt über ZITES einführt, also das ist eine Behörde, die jetzt in, ich glaube, München aufgestellt werden soll, die werden letztendlich auch nicht viel anderes machen, als mit ähnlichen Methoden zu operieren, wenn sie verschlüsselte Chats da Inhalte ran wollen, weil entschlüsseln können sie nicht wirklich, auch wenn die Behörde so heißt. Also das Einzige, was ihnen bleibt, ist auch diese Exploits ankaufen. Und wie gesagt, dass diese, dass diese, dass die, ja, dieses Szenario, da müssen wir halt die Verschlüsselung schwach machen, dass die nicht zielführend ist. Wir sind jetzt in der was? In der dritten, in der vierten Iteration der so genannten Crypto-Wars, wo also genau dieses hin und wieder, was kann man da jetzt machen zwischen Regierung und Hackern bzw. der Netzgesellschaft irgendwie läuft.
Benutzer.
Und letztendlich Benutzern, die dann aber auch ihre Sprachrohre halt auch haben in Richtung der Politik dadurch. Und das hat sich halt gezeigt, dass das dieses einfachen, dann verbieten wir halt für Schlüsselung. Und dann ist es gut, dass das halt auch viel zu kurz greift. Sonst würde die Politik auch anders reagieren, wenn es so einfach wäre.
Warum muss der Geheimdienst oder der Nachrichtendienst überall alles einsehen können? Überhaupt.
Er wird sagen, um unsere Sicherheit gewährleisten zu können.
Zeigt mir doch, dass das jemals funktioniert hat.
Also, ihr würdet sagen, da sind die Interessen eigentlich oder da sollten die Prioritäten eigentlich klar sein. Die Geheimdienste haben gefälligst nicht so vorzugehen. Punkt.
Ja, ich finde ja.
Also so, wie das aktuell passiert, einordentlich.
Ist ja aber jetzt kein realistisches Szenario. Gibt es irgendwas, was tatsächlich in näherer Zukunft passieren könnte, was realistisch ist und was diese ganze Problematik, über die wir jetzt seit fast zwei Stunden reden, entschärfen könnte?
Naja, das ist zwar immer noch nicht gut, aber schon mal ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung. Wenn man eben hingeht und die Amerikaner haben damit tatsächlich schon angefangen. Das funktioniert offensichtlich überhaupt nicht. Eine Art internes Review von eben Sicherheitslücken, die eben für sowas benutzt werden, einführt. Das hätte theoretisch zumindest sowas schon mal verhindern können, aber da sieht man wieder, solange eine allgemeine Geheimdienstkontrolle, also dass überhaupt Geheimdienste in irgendeiner Form kontrolliert werden, kann man halt auch, wenn man jetzt solche Regulierungen aufbaut, nie darauf vertrauen, dass sich daran gehalten wird. Also dass man jetzt sagt, okay, ihr müsst jetzt offenlegen, von mir ist internen Gremium, was ihr da irgendwie habt, und wir sagen, okay, das Spielzeug, das ist viel zu gefährlich für euch, das dürft ihr nicht haben. Aber solange ich jetzt nicht weiß, dass der Geheimdienst seine ganze Spielzeugkiste rausholt, funktioniert das natürlich nicht.
Geheimdienstkontrolle haben wir jetzt auch im entsprechenden Untersuchungsausschuss in anderer Stelle gesehen, ist schwierig, um nicht zu sagen, eigentlich unmöglich. Das schließt halt auch so was mit ein.
Das heißt, alles, was wir wissen, was ich als Nutzer für mich festmachen kann, ist, ich kann mich zumindest halbwegs schützen oder vorbeugen, indem ich die Sachen mache, die wir vorhin besprochen haben, und alles andere ist politisch extrem wichtig eigentlich, wird auch extrem viel diskutiert.
Beteiligt euch, beteiligt euch in dieser Diskussion.
Ja, das kann man machen.
Das ist halt das einzige, was man wie bei jedem politischen Thema sagen kann. Geht in die Diskussion, geht in die Politik, beschäftigt euch, informiert euch. Nur eine aktive Beteiligung kann irgendwas ändern, in welche Richtung auch immer. Wer passiv bleibt, ist letztendlich dem ausgeliefert, was andere entscheiden.
Nimm Stellung, sag, das ist mir nicht okay.
Genau, und das muss ja jetzt auch dann nicht eben technisch sehr ausgefallen sein, sondern man kann auch allgemein sagen, mir gefällt das halt nicht, dass mein Telefon potenziell abgehört wird, damit irgendwelche Terroristen belauscht werden können, bevor sie dann doch irgendwo Bomben zünden.
Ja, und eben das mit dem zeigt mir, dass das funktioniert. Und wenn jetzt meine Privatsphäre verletzt werden soll, dann habe ich keinen Grund zu glauben, dass das funktioniert, nur weil ich etwas opfere, sondern da muss wirklich belegt werden, ganz klar und eindeutig, dass das wirklich wird.
Und zwar nicht hinter irgendeinem komischen Schutzraum, in irgendeinem Gremium, sondern ich möchte das sehen. Und was im Moment passiert, ist das Gegenteil. Die Geheimdienste verlängern Schutzfristen für Geheimhaltung für ihre Akten, dass man sie eben nicht einfach nach so und so vielen Jahren im Bundesarchiv einsehen kann, wo ich zumindest nachvollziehen kann, okay, da hat es funktioniert. Davon ausgehend, dass sich irgendwie in den letzten 25 Jahren nichts verändert hat, sind die auf einem regulatorischen guten Weg. Sowas sehe ich einfach nicht, weil diese Fristen immer weiter verlängert werden.
Die Geheimdienste müssten uns in irgendeiner Form nachvollziehbar zeigen, dass ihre Arbeit wichtig ist und sich lohnt.
Weil unterm Strich müssen wir noch festhalten, es ist eine Demokratie und die funktioniert auch nur, auch bei Geheimdiensten, wo es extrem schwierig ist, in demokratischen Maßstäben. Und soweit man überhaupt eine Compatibilität herstellen kann, muss man das tun und zwar eher mehr als weniger.
So, WannaCry, jetzt haben wir es 10 vor 12. Wir haben gleich noch ein paar Kurzmeldungen zu machen. Ich würde gerne vorher einmal noch dieses Thema versuchen, zusammen zu raufen und irgendwas drunter zu schreiben. Könntet ihr nacheinander, so in ungefähr drei Sätzen, jeder nochmal sagen, was ihr mitnehmt aus dieser ganzen WannaCry-Geschichte, sprich aus der Diskussion darum, aber auch aus dem Vorfall an sich, der jetzt passiert ist. Was ist für euch ganz persönlich eine Konsequenz, eine Erkenntnis? Was nehmt ihr mit? Dannimo, fang an.
Für mich war die Erkenntnis, wie schnell da so ein ausgefeiltes Programm dann doch am Start war, das Sachen getan hat. Das war ja auch, was ich eingangs gesagt hatte, mit denen die Welt nicht gerechnet hat in der Form. Obwohl Experten durchaus informiert waren, aber dass die Welt immer erst dann reagiert, wenn es tatsächlich eine Bedrohung gibt und nicht, wenn Experten waren.
Ich nehme das als Erinnerung auf Updates zu achten, auf Netzwerksicherheit zu achten, dass Systeme wirklich nicht mehr Zugriff oder Dienste offen haben, was sie tatsächlich brauchen.
Gut, ich denke mal, was bei Danimo auch schon so durchklang, dass ein wichtiger Fakt einfach ist, wenn es so Leaks gibt, wo im Wesentlichen nutzungsfertige Exploits drin sind, dass es nicht unwahrscheinlich ist, dass irgendwelche Kriminellen auf die Idee kommen, das zu verwenden, um halt irgendwie monetäre Gewinne zu erzielen, also Ransomware oder ähnliche Kampagnen zu fahren.
Früher oder später.
Wenn es ein Loch gibt, wird das Loch benutzt werden. Sehr wahrscheinlich.
Auf jeden Fall, würde ich sogar sagen. Ob man es mitkriegt, ist eine ganz andere Frage.
Gut, lass uns damit den WannaCry-Sack zumachen. Ihr drei seid vom Chaos Computer Club und ihr möchtet gerne noch ein paar Bekanntmachungen hier machen.
Genau. Und zwar sind ein paar Dinge passiert seit dem letzten Chaos Radio. Wir haben uns nämlich für eine neue Location entschieden für unseren alljährlichen Kongress. Der war ja die ganzen letzten Jahre, nachdem wir aus Berlin weggezogen sind, in Hamburg im Kongresszentrum. Das wird leider gerade umgebaut. Und deswegen findet man uns, wer gerne da teilhaben möchte, ab dem 27. Dezember in der Messe und Kongresszentrum Leipzig. Leipzig?
Karten gibt es schon?
Nee, Karten gibt es noch nicht, aber ich würde empfehlen, schaut euch schon mal um. Ihr wisst ja ungefähr, ab dem 27. bis zum 30. ist das Event. Schaut euch schon mal nach Hotels um, die werden schon mitunter etwas knapp.
Ja, aber schön, Leipzig finde ich schön.
Ja, ist auch von hier gut erreichbar.
Gute Wahl.
Funktioniert. Und eine zweite Sache ist, es gibt für alle Damen, Frauen und die sich als solche fühlen, jetzt einen extra Hackspace in Berlin. Das ist eine relativ neue Sache. Gab es auch vorher schon, aber die haben jetzt wirklich eigene Räumlichkeiten. Wer da mal nachschauen will, besucht den Heart of Code. Die haben jetzt, wie gesagt, eigene Räumlichkeiten auch in Kreuzberg.
Heart of Code, ein Hackerinnen-Space quasi. Sehr coole Leute übrigens. Die haben wir auch auf Fritz schon im Interview gehabt, geht da gerne vorbei auf jeden Fall.
Am Wochenende eröffnet worden.
Und für die jüngeren Zuschauer, es ist jetzt wieder Jugendhackt, schaut mal auf Jugendhackt vorbei. Wir sind jetzt zum Beispiel in Hamburg.
Nicht in Leipzig. Diesmal in Hamburg.
Diesmal in Hamburg. Gibt es aber auch in ganz vielen anderen Städten, schaut euch mal auf der Webseite von Jugendhackt um. Und die Idee ist, dass dort Jugendliche und auch sogar Kinder unter Anleitung von Leuten, die sowas schon länger machen, mit Hard- und Software Dinge basteln können. Es gibt also Projektvorschläge. Es können auch Leute mit eigenen oder die Leute können auch mit eigenen Vorschlägen kommen, was sie denn bauen möchten und werden dann ein bisschen beraten, ob das realistisch ist und wie man das am besten machen kann. Und es macht jede Menge Spaß. Es ist ein Wochenende, in dem man einfach mal so seinen inneren Geek ausprobieren kann.
Da kann man auch sehen, was die letztes Jahr gemacht haben.
Gibt es übrigens auch auf media.ccc.de.
Und dann ist heute nicht nur Himmelfahrt, es ist noch ein Feiertag.
Es ist noch ein Feiertag. Es ist Tower Day.
Muss jetzt aber trotzdem kurz erklären.
Muss ich trotzdem kurz erklären. Es gibt den Anhalter, der Anhalter durch die Galaxis, von Douglas Adams. Der ist jetzt leider schon vor 16 Jahren und zwei Wochen von uns gegangen. Aber dieser Tower Day, den gibt es schon relativ lange. Und da tragen Anhänger dieses Werkes immer ein Tuch um den Hals oder mit sich rum. Und das hat folgende Bewandtnis, der Protagonist sagt in Anhalter durch die Galaxis, dass ein Handtuch so ziemlich das Nützlichste ist, was man auf Reisen mit sich führen kann.
Kann man schon mal so postulieren.
Also wenn ihr Leute, wenn ihr Leute seht heute, die mit dem Handtuch rumgerannt sind, aber gar nicht so ausgesehen haben, als ob sie jetzt einen Marathon gelaufen wären, die erinnern euch daran, lest das vielleicht mal.
Oder die kamen im Bollerwagen vom See, ist auch eine Möglichkeit. Das kann auch sein, dass sie Douglas Adams zelebrieren wollten. Das war das Chaos Radio im Blue Moon auf Fritz. Ich sage herzlichen Dank an Danimo vom Chaos Computer Club.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Peter ebenfalls vom CCC.
Vielen Dank, ciao.
Alex war auch dabei.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Und die ganze Rutsche gibt es wie immer auch im Podcast. Ich würde gerne schließen mit den Worten I wanna cry. Es gibt Musik jetzt von Tracky Birthday Website. Tschüss.